Guten Morgen, liebe. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ja, wir sind zu tief getauft. Wir müssen jetzt durchs Deep Fepp zurück ins Cleanet und dann ans Surfals-Web.
Lobbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer einhundertneunundachtzig und nach drei Wochen haben wir es geschafft aus den äh untiefen der,
dunklen Materie wieder äh aufzusteigen in euren sichtbaren Raum am äh,
versucht zu senden, aber irgendwie sind unsere Radiowellen durch ein schwarzes Loch irgendwie nicht so richtig über den Ereignishorizont äh hinweggekommen, denn es war irgendwie auch alles so ein bisschen bedrückend.
Ja, die Nachrichten waren nicht so gut, ne?
Ne, es hielt sich wirklich in Grenzen. Das war wirklich so, so. Ah, wie was ist passiert? Na, dann lege ich mich mal wieder hin oder weitertanzen.
Mir fällt auf, ich bin verflucht leise. Ich sehe das sogar, ich sehe meine Well, meine meine Strahlen auf dem, auf der Visualisierung da, auf deinem Spektrometer.
Ach nee, das ist alles gar nicht so schlimm, das äh täuscht. Aber wenn du ein bisschen mehr mehr Wumps äh haben willst.
Wums, jawohl, hier, zack.
Ja, Hörer hat jetzt natürlich keinen Unterschied gemerkt, das ist alles nur in deinem nur alles in deiner Vorstellung, alles nur in deiner eigenen Realität, in deinem eigenen Darknet sozusagen.
Das ist ein von Suchmaschinen nicht äh indiz.
Ihr seht schon wieder die Stellvorlagen müssen unbedingt äh angegangen werden, also da die Flügelstürmer jetzt sich nicht endlich aus dem Schuppen rauskommen,
dann weiß ich auch nicht. Von daher sind wir jetzt wieder aufgestellt. Wir haben eine kleine Pause gemacht die war ähm
Ja, schon so ein bisschen Sommerinduziert, würde ich sagen und das geht unter Umständen auch noch ein bisschen weiter durch äh diesen Sommer. Ihr wisst ja, im Podcastland ist immer Sommerpause ein großes Ding,
Das wird uns sicherlich auch betreffen, auch wenn wir noch keine Zusagen machen können, wie lange es denn nun äh dauernd wird, äh die eine oder andere Option zeichnet sich,
auch noch ab.
Vor allem wir haben ja unsere Urlauber eingereicht, aber in Würzburg, München und Ansbach hat man sich einfach nicht dran gehalten, ne? Das ist wirklich Urlaub abgelehnt.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein Problem, ja. Ja, Bayern wirft uns immer irgendwelche Knüppel zwischen die Beine.
Wir warten mal kurz noch Feedback. Wir haben nämlich relativ viele, wir haben gute Kommentare wie immer bekommen.
Mhm.
Ähm einmal Tesla, äh ich hatte.
Äh glaube ich, im Nebensatz die verschiedenen Sensoren des Modell S aufgelistet, dabei auch die Rückfahrkamera erwähnt, die wird
aber nicht bei der Autopilot-Hardware genutzt. Äh darauf werden wir in den Kommentaren,
hingewiesen. Die Rückfahrkamera ist nicht Teil der Autopilot-Hardware und die Hand am Lenkraderkennung erfolgt, wie von Tim auch richtig vermutet. Durch Widerstand gegen den Motor, der das Lenkrad dreht.
Ja, also dadurch die die diese skurrile Geschichte mit den Bananen funktioniert, also auch mit Äpfeln, wenn man äh entsprechend die beiden Kabelbinder über Kreuz macht, ne? Weil Apfel ist schwieriger dran zu machen als eine Banane,
Birne geht auch ähm.
Und dann noch die, der Hinweis, die Polizei hat einen mobilen DVD-Player im Wagen bestätigt auf dem iPad, der also dem dem.
Dem Touchscreen.
Touch äh Screen des Armaturenbretts des Testes Leers. Ähm,
kann man keine Videos wiedergeben, dass äh das war schon immer so, dass es auch äh also das, dass diese Bildschirme eben während der Fahrt sich weigern, also bei der soweit die Reportelektronik merkt, wie ich bewege mich, äh geht der geht der Film aus
Deswegen muss man dann doch nochmal, ne?
Mobilen DVD Player.
Aus, also genug Geld ausgegeben, dann musste der noch so ein äh mobilen DVD DVBT-Gerät da reinstellen. Das ist eigentlich auch ein Witz, ja.
Ähm.
Na ja, aber nachvollziehbar. Ich meine, würdest du das anders bummieren? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
So, dann ähm wurde gesagt äh
haben wir, glaube ich, nicht aus, haben wir nicht ausreichend darauf hingewiesen, äh sofort überweisen könnte, ein maximal bei einer Überweisung bescheißen, wenn man nicht drauf achtet, viel problematischer ist aber, dass man ihnen einen Zugang zu den ganzen Kontoeinstellungen und dem Verlauf gibt durch die gleichbleibende PIM.
Und äh der Kommentator erinnert sich, dass da mal jemand geprüft hat und rausgekommen ist, dass sofort Überweisungen so driveby mäßig.
Auch gleich mal die Kontoüberweisung der letzten drei Monate ähm abgreift. Äh Daueraufträge und so weiter. Äh das macht natürlich auch Sinn, weil die ja quasi gucken wollen, okay.
Ist zu erwarten, dass dieses Geld hier drauf ist und äh dann kann man das ja direkt mit in so ein Scoring des Kunden äh einfließen lassen und so weiter. Also die man gibt denen natürlich durch diese Pin äh,
Zugang zu den Kontobewegungen und zwar dauerhaft. Das haben wir nicht ausreichend darauf hingewiesen.
Und das ist wirklich belegt, dass die darauf zugreifen oder ist das eine Vermutung? So, so.
Hab ihn jetzt nicht nochmal gesucht, aber du, also ist eigentlich auch scheißegal, ja? Wenn ich dir den Schlüssel zu meiner Wohnung gebe, dann hast du Zugang dazu, jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob du dann abends in meiner Unterwäsche wühlst, aber allein der Gedanke, dass es ginge, sollte ausreichend beunruhigend sein.
Es besteht überhaupt gar keinen Grund zur Beunruhigung. Ich habe bisher noch überhaupt nichts verdächtiges gefunden. Also.
So, dann haben wir äh noch einen äh Kommentar, der auch, denke ich, ganz äh ganz wichtig ist vor dem Hintergrund. Es stört mich massiv, dass terroristische Propaganda grundsätzlich verboten werden soll.
Persönlich nutze das Internet, um mich über terroristische Organisationen wie den Islamischen Staat zu informieren. Dazu gehört die Auseinandersetzung mit der Außen- und
Selbstdarstellung.
Denke ich auch. Er berichtet weiterhin, dass es in verschiedenen Redits, die sich damit auseinandersetzen, äh Sub Redits und Foren zusehends auffällt, dass die Leute Furcht davor haben, auf einer Liste zu landen.
Ich freue mich jeden Tag,
Ich freue mich auf den Tag, an dem ein Spezialkommando mir die Bude aufmacht, weil ich mich frei informiert habe. Ich möchte in einen Staat leben, in dem ich mich frei informieren kann. Ähm
Abschließend möchte ich zur Sicherheit klarstellen, dass ich terroristische Akte grundsätzlich verurteile also.
Deine IP-Adresse haben wir schon weitergegeben. Ähm ja,
das äh denke ich auch und äh da gibt's eine äh interessante Episode des Podcasts Metrolaut Metrolaut heißt der,
ja? Äh die sich mit der äh terroristischen Propaganda auseinandersetzt, so heißt das Metrolaut fünfundzwanzig Kultur des äh die wir an der Stelle auch nochmal verlinken. Die Kollegen von Metrolot, übrigens Tim haben ihren Podcast auf,
TLS Omly umgeschaltet. Und es scheint zu funktionieren. Mit Blitz and Crypt,
Keine Beschwerden bisher. Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie du dich jetzt hier dauerhaft aus der Nummer noch. Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht schmiert den auch demnächst alles ab, aber ähm,
Bis jetzt geben sie damit an und haben auf jeden Fall die Pole Position inne. Wie lassen wir das? Lassen wir das.
Ja das können wir auch nach der Sendung gerne nochmal diskutieren aber die Umstellung der Meterebene auf eine neue äh.
Für dich schwierig.
Ja nicht nur schwierig, aber sie gestaltet sich, also sie sie ist seit äh längerer Zeit in Transition. Nur muss halt sehr viel getestet werden, weil das eben,
nur ein neuer Server, sondern neues PRP, Pipapo, alles Mögliche, also sozusagen eine Generalüberholung der Gesamtinstallation. Da muss halt alles getestet werden und das ist bei mir halt recht viel.
Also neues PAP hört sich so ein bisschen an wie bei so einem achtundsechzig Jahre alten Ford Fiesta nochmal neue Reifen.
Lassen wir das du, ich will.
Und Hexspoiler.
Oder doch nochmal Kupplung machen lassen, weißt du? Getriebeschaden, nochmal repariert.
Habe ich gelesen, soll geil sein.
Bringt fünf PS.
Total total ab.
So kommen wir zum Terrorteil.
Ja, der geht nämlich auch total ab irgendwie, also während wir uns äh versucht haben, so ein bisschen den Bauch in die Sonne zu drehen und äh doch die ein oder andere Entspannung äh über uns ergehen zu lassen. Brach irgendwie so äh mal wieder die Gesellschaft weg.
Und hatte ja allen Anlass sich zu äh aufzuregen, dass,
tut sie ja äh gerne durch eine absurde Häufung und Serie von Gewalttaten, die stattfanden mit sehr unterschiedlichen
Hintergründen, was natürlich in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung dann nicht unbedingt immer so diversifiziert wahrgenommen wird, auch wenn das ein oder andere Outlet sich äh durchaus bemüht hat, hier
Feinheiten zu unterscheiden. Wir wissen, wie das in der derzeitigen Aufgeregtheit der Gesellschaft wahrscheinlich dann in der Summe wahrgenommen wird. Wahrscheinlich nicht so differenziert.
Aber wir können's ja mal versuchen, etwas differenzierter zu betrachten. Wo hat's eigentlich zuerst geknallt.
Also ihr die Reihenfolge, da machen wir jetzt den ersten Fehler. Ich habe eine äh also die das war ja so viel. Ich glaube, das erste war Würzburg. Das war dieser ähm das war dieser Depp mit der Axt im Regionalexpress. Der ähm.
Da mehrere Menschen mit Akt, mit mit Beil und Messer angegriffen hat und dann irgendwie wenn ich das richtig rekonstruiert habe äh mit vier Kugeln,
vor der Polizei niedergestreckt wurde, worüber sich dann Renate Künast aufgeregt hat.
Aufgeregt hat sie sich nicht, sie hat eine Frage gestellt, die ich ehrlich gesagt auch ziemlich berechtigt fand.
Ähm ja, die ist berechtigt. Ähm die Frage ist berechtigt, aber die hat sie natürlich äh sage ich mal strategisch äh zum zu einem unklugen Zeitpunkt gestellt. Ähm,
Die Schilderung war jetzt irgendwie so. Letztendlich hat der Typ sich wohl irgendwie abseits der Gleise im Gebüsch versteckt und auch sehr
ist aus nächster Nähe auf die Polizisten mit einem Ball losgegangen und die haben dann eben
tödlich geschossen, wobei Polizisten eigentlich angehalten sind, die er auf die Beine zu schießen und äh dich nicht äh zu töten.
Ähm wir hatten vor einigen Jahren in Berlin mal einen Fall, wo ein ähm geistig gestörter oder geistig.
Vom guten Rathaus, ne, an den Brunn.
Ja, der ist vom roten Rathaus in den Brunnen rumgerannt, nackt mit dem Messer und dann ist ein Polizist in in einem.
Glanzvollen Einfall zu dem in diesen Brunnen gestiegen. Der Mann ist dann und ist auf denen zugegangen mit gezogener Waffe. Der Mann hat dann eine Bewegung in dessen Richtung mit dem Messer gemacht und der Polizist hat den getödlich getroffen.
Das war ein klarer Fall von so nicht,
Der Polizist hätte nichts, hatte nichts in diesem scheiß Brunnen verloren. Ähm der Polizist hatte nichts damit verloren, auf nackten Mann zu schießen, sich dem überhaupt zu nähern, wenn der ein Messer hat, da kann man die Frage stellen, wenn der Regionalexpress äh voller Blut ist ähm,
und der Mann mit der Axt auf die Polizisten zurennt, ähm dann sind auch die vier Kugeln bei zwei Polizisten genau das, was die machen sollen, ne? Zwei Schüsse,
Das geht so klack, klack und äh.
Wie gesagt, sehr schön gewesen, dem noch Fragen zu stellen. Ähm es war und es ist grundsätzlich auch eine Frage, die man sich stellen muss, muss die soll die Polizei töten.
Äh in einem solchen Fall aber äh ja da hat sie also zu einem die Frage hat sie äh zu einem ähm Öffentlichkeitswirksam, sehr ungünstigen Moment äh gestellt.
Äh genau, da hatten wir also den Irren mit der Axt. Ähm das, wie war das da, war da, der wurde dann ähm,
von dem von dem IS gefeiert und von dem taucht da auch irgend so ein Video auf, in dem er irgendwie erzählte er würde sich jetzt an den Koffer rächen oder sowas, ne? Ähm.
Sicher war das nicht Ansbach. Oh Gott, jetzt komme ich durcheinander. Das ist das Problem, Manu kannst du gar nicht mehr überblicken. Okay.
Das weiß ich. Das Video habe ich hier äh gesehen im Internet.
Ich war da im Off.
Der hatte auch einen äh Geflüchteten, der hatte einen geflüchteten Hintergrund, war relativ junger Mann. Ähm.
Dann hatten wir, glaube ich, jetzt weiß ich nicht, was äh ob erst München oder erst Ansbach kam.
Ich glaube München.
München ähm ein äh Rechtsradikaler Idiot mit Knarre. Äh,
Hatte irgendwie äh,
hat dann da irgendwie rumgeballert und mehrere Menschen getötet in einem vor, also er hat den auch vor allem McDonald's rumgeschossen oder mehrere Menschen verletzt, hat in diesem Olympia-Einkaufszentrum rumgeballert ähm.
Und äh ja war glaube ich teils Syrer, teils deutscher und hatte aber irgendwie letztendlich war seine iranisch, okay, äh.
Iranisch, Deutsch hielt sich selber für ein Arier das Kernproblem bei dem Menschen war offenbar,
ungesicherte Erkenntnislage, aber soweit ich das wahrgenommen habe, einfach jemand, der äh.
Sehr ja ähm vermutlich auch einfach unter Depressionen äh Litt einfach generell auch einfach kein, kein eigenes Umfeld in dem Sinne hatte, sehr ausgegrenzt war
gut, ich meine, wenn jetzt irgendwelche
Deutsch-Iraner anfangen sich irgendwie für Arier äh zu halten und irgendeiner äh rechtsradikalen äh Gesinnung nacheifern, weil äh sie mal von Türken oder wem auch immer äh zusammengeschlagen wurden, denn dann dann kann man da einfach keine klare, ideologische Zuordnung machen. Das
war einfach.
Scheidende, der entscheidende Punkt ist der Typ war äh in der Psychiatrie Aktenkundig, hat seine Medikamente abgesetzt und hat dann da irgendwie diesen
Es hat dann da diesen diesen Amoklauf da äh gestartet. Ähm da fand ich übrigens sehr interessant, auch da gab es ja ein Video, zwei Videos, krass, krasse Videos. Ähm sehr schön fand ich, wie er da auf diesem,
rummarschiert
und ihr wieder da rumschreit. Ich bin Deutscher und so weiter und man hört eine andere Stimme. Ich weiß nicht, ob das die Person ist, die filmt oder eine andere aber so ein bayerische Stimme, die also,
das fand ich echt sehr geil. Also ich bin Deutscher und der und der Typ einfach nur du bist ein Wichser, bist du.
Also das reicht. Da habe ich wieder gedacht, okay, also wenn du ein, wenn du alle Hoffnung an.
Äh dann dann kommen die dann doch nochmal mit.
Du bist ein Mixer bist du. Der äh der fruchtet dann da rum.
Korrekt.
Und vorher äh gibt's das andere Video ist der der kommt also wirklich aus diesem McDonald's raus und schießt da ähm,
sofort auf irgendwelche äh Innos and Bice Tennis, die in dem Video aber so sieht es aus, alle noch lebend aus dem Bild rennen.
Ähm und der Typ, der filmt, rennt wirklich also auch ein. Weißt du, rennt um die nächste Ecke.
Und bleibt aber dann stehen und sagt, Alter, wie krank ist der denn?
So mein Kommentar wäre, ich hätte mir noch fünf Ecken mehr gesucht und hätte die Bullen gerufen, äh bevor ich stehen geblieben. Gut, äh aber er hat dann auch andere Menschen gewarnt. Vorsicht, er ist einer mit einer mit einer Waffe. Ja, diese Videos waren ähm.
Ähm ja eindrucksvoll. Äh dann hatten wir in indoor auch noch in Deutschland, in Ansbach ähm jemand, der hatte dann wirklich IS-Hintergrund, ne, der einen Selbstmord äh er beigeführt hat durch Explosion. Und dabei.
Mehr so um mich herum stehende Menschen verletzt hat und der Stand ähm vor einem.
Vor dem Einlass zu einem Musikfest.
Wo er nicht reingelassen wurde im Übrigen.
Ja deswegen aber das hatte was, ja. Ähm kurz zu also.
Dann hatten wir glaube ich noch in Frankreich, die ähm die Arschlöcher, die in die Kirche gegangen sind und den Priester getötet haben.
Und ich möchte jetzt an der Stelle kurz das Claimer alle diese Dinge, alle diese Schilderungen habt ihr gesehen, sehr kurz und überspitzt und das mache ich hauptsächlich um unserer äh Chronistenpflicht nachzukommen, also bitte erwartet hier keine,
vollständige Erfassungen dieser ähm Vorkommnisse. Das ist eben,
Nicht der Fokus dieses Podcasts und fall Zeit da meine etwas flapsige und zynische Art dazu, aber anders ist es mir inzwischen auch nicht mehr möglich ähm damit umzugehen.
Ja, hier geht's um Kontextualisierung, damit wir jetzt sozusagen die äh Forderung und die netzpolitischen Forderungen, die sich daraus ergeben
entsprechend äh spiegeln können, ne? Ja
ganze fand ja nun in Bayern statt kein Wunder, dass hier unsere Freunde von der CSU gleich als erste an der Startlinie stehen, ja?
Da hat man auch immer schon die passenden Listen in der Schublade bereit, die für in solchen Momenten dann herausgezogen werden und ja.
Also man muss vielleicht hier schon auch zu kontextualisierung äh sagen ähm.
Dass Deutschland oder insbesondere Angela Merkel sich entschieden hat, ähm für viele Geflüchtete den Zugang,
zu ermöglichen. Auch zu Zeiten
kontrolliert. Äh oder mit sehr schwachen Kontrollen erstmal Tür auf und äh alle in Sicherheit. Äh da war Horst Seehofer,
der CSU-Vorsitzende derjenige, der da massiv sich von Anfang an gegen gewährt hat.
Und ähm dass nun mit diesen Wahl bei bei zwei dieser Fälle,
es sich um Menschen handelt, die als Geflüchtete sich in Deutschland gemeldet haben, ähm ist natürlich etwas, was,
den Horst Seehofer in die Verzweiflung treibt, also der stellt sich da jetzt auch nicht hin und sagt äh hier habe ich doch gesagt, Agebad, der sieht sich natürlich bestätigt und ähm da da kriegt es also kriegen all diese.
Vorkommnisse nochmal eine ganz andere Bedeutung für eben den seit Monaten sehr massiv ausgetragenen in der Öffentlichkeit auch ausgetragenen Streit zwischen Angela Merkel und Horst Seehofer,
den wir auch hier jetzt nochmal weiterhin ein bisschen ausklammern wollen.
Aber der ähm denke ich hier erwähnt sein muss. Ähm die CSU hat darauf reagiert mit einem Forderungskatalog der ihr diesmal mit dem Titel Sicherheit durch Stärke.
Überschrieben wurde, finde ich eine etwas unglückliche Wahl.
Ja, ich auch.
Also
dass ich weiß, das erinnert mich in, das hat für mich komische Kondotationen. Äh aber inhaltlich ist es auch jetzt nichts, nichts anderes als sie vielleicht ohnehin schon vorher äh gefordert haben. Äh Joachim Herrmann, der bayrische Innenminister.
Kündigte an, okay, mehr Personal und bessere Ausrüstung für für die Polizei hat aber keine Zahlen genannt, ja? Also sagt er
Grundsätzlich machen wir das jetzt. Polizei muss besser ausgestattet werden. Klar, was soll der Innenminister auch sonst sagen?
Man sich natürlich, warum sie dazu jetzt erst äh sich durchringen, wenn sie die ganze Zeit schon so eine Position haben. Das äh.
Sie müssen.
Genau und man sieht aber auch hätte keines dieser Vorkommnisse hättest du mit mit mehr äh Polizei oder bessere Ausrüstung nennenswert verhindern können. Das ist ja gerade genau das ekelhafte daran.
Ähm mehr Kontrollen, eine Politik der offenen Grenzen darf es nicht geben.
Ebenfalls Zitat Hermann. Schon bei der Erstkontrolle einer geflüchteten Person an der Grenze müsse die Polizei die Identität klären.
Schöne Vorstellung, aber wahrscheinlich komplett unrealisierbar.
Na ja, Grenzen zumachen ist schon realisi.
Meine die Erstkontrolle und die Identität klären, also das ist sehr schwierig wenn Personen ankommen ohne Dokumente sagen sie sind aus Syrien äh wie willst du da ohne umfassende ähm,
Fremdsprachliche analytische Kenntnisse in irgendeiner Form.
Na ja, also in dem Satz äh bei der Erstkontrolle muss die Polizei die Identität klären, heißt natürlich auch.
Wenn sie nicht geklärt ist, tschüs.
Dann findet die Erstkontrolle, wird, ihr findet die Erstkontrolle eben keinen Abschluss, ne? Ähm.
Allgemein strengerer Umgang mit Geflüchteten und Asylbewerbern äh schnelleres Abschieben ermöglichen,
Gut, jetzt hätten sie den Würzburger mit der Axt leben lassen, hätten sie ihn vielleicht noch abschieben können, ja? Ähm wobei da hätten sie wahrscheinlich auch drauf verzichtet und den lieber in Deutschland nochmal eingekehrt hat. Insofern auch das eine Förderförderung.
Das war doch derjenige, der auch abgeschoben werden sollte, ne? War das der in Würzburg oder war das denn München nicht in Würzburg? Ja ja.
Ähm.
Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann, das überlagert sich alles. Entschuldigt, unsere Verwirrung, aber äh es war auf jeden Fall einer, den der in München nicht. Ich glaube, ist bez.
Einer wurde, einer wurde geduldet und Asyl, der an der Antrag auf Asyl war abgelehnt worden und er befand sich in der Duldung.
Ja, ich glaube, das war der Typ genan.
So, also schneller abschieben, auch jetzt nichts, was dem Terror irgendwie Einheit gebieten wird.
Was ich vor allem auch nicht so ohne Weiteres beschleunigen lässt, weil das ja auch äh nicht nur ein ein deutsches Problem ist, sondern sozusagen auch ein Problem in der Auseinandersetzung mit den Ländern, wohin abgeschoben werden soll, weil die müssen die ja auch annehmen und das tun diese dann eben auch häufig nicht.
Und man möchte die Flüchtlingsunterkünfte überwachen. Da werden die sich freuen, die Leute.
Auch hier vielleicht kurz zur Kontextualisierung. Äh diese Flüchtlingsunterkünfte sind wirklich kein schöner Ort, ne? Also das sind da äh sind Menschen auf engem Raum, die ähm teilweise,
oder größtenteils sehr krasse Reisen und Erlebnisse hinter sich haben
der kracht es naturgemäß andauernd. Ähm das schönste Zitat dazu war glaube ich schon vor längerer Zeit. Ich glaube, das war eine Grünen oder Linken Politikerin, die sagte, wenn man den Bundestag auch nur einen Tag zusammen in der Turnhalle
sperren würde, würden. Schlimmere Dinge passieren. Ähm.
Kannst du dich da nicht dran erinnern.
Nein, das kannte ich noch nicht, aber der Gedanke, den finde ich faszinierend. Man stellt sich nur vor, irgendwie Sarah Wagenknecht, also irgendwie.
Müssen wir müssen gemeinsam an in einer Schlange anstehen fürs Essen.
So, dann ähm kommen wir zu den sportlichen Forderungen äh Bundeswehreinsatz im Inneren, nicht nur bei Waldbrand und Flut. Ähm,
dass die Bundeswehr kein äh nicht im Innern eingesetzt werden darf, hat eine äh lange Tradition und historische Begründung in Deutschland. Ähm,
die Überzeugung ist, dass eine Armee, die den Namen wehr
äh im Namen hat eben nur zur Abwehranwendung finden soll und keine Angriffs äh Kriege führen soll. Gut, das haben wir irgendwann in den seit den neunziger Jahren hinter uns, das mit den Angriffskriegen, aber äh wir,
die haben also die Bundeswehr darf,
grundsätzlich erstmal nur äh zur Abwehr von Naturkatastrophen im im Innern eingesetzt werden und sammelt dann eben alle zehn Jahre mal große Sympathiepunkte durch das Aufschichten von Sandsäcken. Ähm,
Hier wird die äh Überlegung oder es wird immer wieder die Überlegung angestellt. Das ist doch auch toll wäre, wenn man mit diesen ganzen Kampfmitteln auch in Deutschland quasi.
Polizeiaufgaben erledigen könnte, um nichts anderes geht es hier eine sehr gefährliche Forderung.
Ähm für die es ein äh für und wieder gibt ähm.
Diese Forderung steht auf jeden Fall jetzt hier erstmal im Raum. Ähm dann natürlich der Ausbau der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
ähm denn im Kampf gegen den Terrorismus müssten Verbindungsdaten länger als nur zehn Wochen gespeichert äh werden, sagte dann der Justizminister Winfried Bausback.
Und ähm Seehofer hat dann abschließend nochmal sehr unverhohlen Angela Merkel gedroht. Äh er würde Merkel in Zukunft in der Flüchtlingsfrage kaum noch entgegenkommen.
Er sei nicht mehr bereit, nur um das Friedenswillen die Dinge nicht zu behandeln, wie sie behandelt werden müssten,
Also diese dieser Merkel Seehofer Konflikt erfährt hier natürlich eine neue ähm einen neuen Höhepunkt.
Wie nicht anders zu erwarten war.
Genau, Justizminister in Bayern, der Bauspark.
Dass dass also die Drohung war von Seehofer direkt. Dann äh zog Merkel ihre Sommerpresse Pressekonferenz vor.
Und ähm wich aber jetzt konkret der Frage nach konkreten Maßnahmen aus und sagte na gut, wir haben.
Vorratsahnspeicherung dieses Jahr bekommen. Wir haben ein Antiterror-Paket, wir haben den Austausch von Flugasdaten, äh wir haben diese Anonymität von SIM-Karten werden wir in Zukunft aus äh äh auslöschen.
Das heißt wir sind maßnahmenmäßig eigentlich ziemlich gut aufgestellt und äh wir werden aber äh zwei Dinge jetzt auf jeden Fall nochmal vorantreiben.
Und,
hier belohnt sich nochmal zurückzublicken auf welche Taten wir hier blicken, ne? Wir blicken auf einen Mann, der mit einer Axt im Regionalexpress, wir wir blicken auf einen Mann mit einer Knarre im McDonald's und wir blicken auf ein
Man mit einer äh mit einer Explosion mit einer mit einer Bombenweste. Ja, bei einem Musikfest.
Hier also die Maßnahme von Angela Merkel ähm die neue Entschlüsselungsbehörde Zitis, wir hatten sie hier, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung schon
ausführlich behandelt. Die zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich die als Dienstleister für Bundespolizei, Verfassungsschutz
Bundeskriminalamt ähm fungieren soll und Internetkommunikation,
entschlüsseln soll, soll stärker vorangetrieben werden. Ja, geil, also ein Plan, der ohnehin schon da war, soll jetzt noch schneller ausgeführt werden. Ich glaube, ich hatte schon darauf hingewiesen, dass die Zitis.
Glaube ich mit zweihundert Planstellen eingeplant ist ähm da wird man sich also fragen, wie soll ich mein,
Ihr werdet keine zehn kriegen, ja? Ähm insofern weiß ich nicht, wie sie das jetzt weiter beschleunigen sollen. Ähm die Behörde soll,
aber ja auch äh die die zur Entschlüssung notwendigen Technologien entwickeln oder von Firmen kaufen. Ich denke, um das schnell voranzutreiben, wird man kaufen müssen. Der Beleg, wie damit dann.
Auch nur irgendwie eine dieser Taten verhindert werden, verhindert worden werden sein soll, äh, steht dann noch aus.
Und außerdem sagt sie, na ja, die Zusammenarbeit zwischen BND und ausländischen Diensten müsse ausgebaut werden,
und das sei im BND-Gesetz ja auch schon prima formuliert und,
Grundrechtsschonend umgesetzt. So und das das BND-Gesetz, von dem sie das spricht, das ist genau das, was wir hier in den letzten Folgen immer wieder besprochen haben, wo Anna so auch so, dass Anna auch so gut dargestellt hat, Annabi Selli von Netzwerk Org,
dass es das Gesetz, was im Prinzip vieles, was zuvor illegal war.
Ähm legalisiert und das im Prinzip genau diese Zusammenarbeit zwischen BND und ausländischen Diensten ist das Hauptthema des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses.
Und auch hier.
Ist die englische Methode.
Der Nachweis, auch hier fehlt der Anhalt, ist es gibt noch nicht mal den Anhaltspunkt, dass NSA oder irgendein ausländischer Dienst über diese eine dieser drei Personen irgendwelche Daten gehabt hätte,
Das wäre ja, ich meine, das wäre das Minimum gewesen zu sagen, hier. Ähm,
Wenn die NSA wollte uns die Daten geben durfte aber nicht und und deswegen äh ist der Typ jetzt hier auf dem Musikfest geplatzt.
Ja, deswegen deswegen konnten sie nicht den Panzer die Rolltreppe im Einkaufszentrum hochschicken, der während er zu McDonald's fährt, irgendwie äh die äh unverschlüsselten Nachrichten entschlüsselt.
Das einzige, was man.
Das ist ja übrigens auch noch äh was wir gar nicht erwähnt haben, also in diese äh in allen Fällen, wenn ich das richtig überblicke, gibt es keine Berichte über Nutzung
von verschlüsselter
Kommunikation zwischen Beteiligten, ja? Äh Thema Danknet äh kommen wir gleich noch so. Ähm aber sozusagen Chatverläufe wurden dort irgendwie analysiert et cetera und äh von daher nicht äh.
Äh ja die Flasche hätte ich gerne gereicht.
Die Flasche, ich reiße dir auch gerne welche von den beiden hättest du den gehen? Die schwarz oder die weiß vorne das. Das ist dann dein äh dein Podcast Doping.
Ja genau. Ja. Ähm.
Ja. Ja, also du schüttelst mit dem Kopf, aber ich.
Ja, also ist mit dem Kopf aber Verschlüsselung spielt, spielt dann schon eine Rolle, wenn es um äh um die, diese Darknet-Geschichte geht, ne.
Meinte ich ja gerade, aber sozusagen die diese. Auch hier hätte das äh wenig geholfen. Äh die aktive Entschlüsselung von Kommunikation vorzunehmen.
Äh blicken wir aber mal positiv immerhin Angela Merkel,
fordert keine Ausweitung des bisher bestehenden. Das ist, ich meine, das ist bei aller, bei allem, worauf wir hier blicken, echt was Positives, ja? Äh im Gegensatz zu den äh bayrischen Leuten, die allerlei Ausweitungen,
fordern Bundeswehr Minern, äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung bis Arno Dunnemals, ja, sagt Angela Merkel im Prinzip nichts anderes als das, was wir ohnehin schon haben schneller
Das muss man, das muss man bei allem echt mal zugute halten, das ist, das ist da freuen wir inzwischen schon dumm, ne, wenn der Notfrisst der Teufel
fliegen. So, aber natürlich.
Mit der mit dem dadurch das Grundrechte ja jetzt umfassend gewahrt sind im BN im neuen BND-Gesetz beendet Angela Merkel im Prinzip natürlich auch den NSA-Skandal. Sie sagt das was wir hier, was jetzt drei Jahre lang ähm Thema war.
Ähm ja, machen wir jetzt, das müssen wir jetzt ausbauen. Ist auch völlig in Ordnung.
Also so viel zu den deutschen ähm Reaktionen.
Und jetzt kommen wir nochmal zu einem spezifischen Thema, äh was dann ähm einmal vor diesem Hintergrund,
München eine Rolle gespielt hat und dann nochmal äh spezifisch nochmal eine Rolle gespielt hat. Ähm.
Nämlich die dunkle Seite der Macht.
Genau, mit der mit der mit dem Lage bricht Cybercrime äh Cyber Crime des BKA des Bundeskriminalamtes.
Und äh dieses Thema hat die das Thema Darknet. Hat im Prinzip die ganze Woche äh bestimmt.
Seit nämlich ich glaube mit ich hab's zuerst mit einer in einer Spiegel-Online-Recherche gelesen, kann aber auch sein, dass es äh woanders herkam.
Da sich nämlich Anhaltspunkte fanden, dass der Münchener Täter äh die Tatwaffe einen äh österreichisches Modell der äh,
der Marke Glock siebzehn glaube ich oder neunzehn heißt das kommt, das unterscheidet glaube ich die Anzahl der Schüsse im Magazin. Ähm.
Über eine Darknet-Plattform zumindest gesucht hat. Und zwar fand man also ähm.
In verschiedenen Onlinemarktplätzen, die sich im Darknet befinden, geh Suche nach Waffen. Ähm und zwar nach dieser spezifischen Waffe. Und äh.
Am Ende hatte der Täter von München eben auch äh diese äh spezifische Waffe.
Und jetzt stellte sich die Frage, wie kann das denn sein, ne? Äh das Darknet äh darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein, ähm dass er sich da eine Knarre äh.
Besorgt hat und.
Vor allen Dingen möchte ich noch ganz kurz im Hintergrund sagen, das was ich finde im im in den verschiedenen Onlinemarktplätzen im Darknet sind,
Wie gesagt, Gesuche und auf Frustrationsäußerungen darüber, dass er eben keine Knarre findet und nach meiner Kenntnis bisher,
steht der Beweis aus, dass er sie auch tatsächlich dort gefunden hat. Ähm! Es mag sein, dass
Ermittler schon heute irgendwie durch eine forensische Untersuchung des Computers wissen oder wissen können oder bald wissen werden, dass er sie tatsächlich über Starknet hat. Bisher gibt es, steht dieser Beweis aber aus und als ich gestern in den die letzten Meldungen dazu noch studiert habe, stand auch das noch einmal da drin,
wenn auch in den wenigsten.
Dann gab es eine spannende Äußerung des äh Bundesinnenministerium in der Bundespressekonferenz, wo dann das Cleanet und das Darknet und das Deepseb und das Surface-Web erklärt wurden.
Ähm.
Webs muss ich sagen, die mir zu diesem Zeitpunkt so noch gar nicht bekannt waren.
Also dieser Begriff Service-Web stammt wohl aus irgend so einer Studie von zweitausenddrei und dieser Begriff Cleanet, den hat glaube ich keiner vorher gehört. Ähm.
Ne. Ähm das ist auch wirklich weit hergeholt.
Na ja, also dann stellte am wahrscheinlich am Mittwoch,
Wenn mich jetzt nicht alles täuscht, das BKA sein Lagebericht Cybercrime vor.
Und äh schilderte darin durch Computer und Internetkriminalität ist im vergangenen Jahr, also zweitausendfünfzehn ein registrierter Schaden von mehr als vierzig einhalb Millionen Euro entstanden.
Man habe mehr als fünfundvierzigtausend Fälle von Cyberkriminalität äh in Deutschland gezählt.
Und die Aufklärungsquote liege bei rund dreiunddreißig Prozent. Cybercrime definiert das BKI in diesem Lagebericht so, dass der, dass es den Bereich der Straftaten abdecke, die sich,
gegen das Internet, Datennetze, Informationstechnisches Theme oder deren Daten richten oder,
Die Mittels dieser Informationstechnik begangen wurden. Also nehmen wir mal ähm das Beispiel
klassisch klassisches Beispiel, dieser Enkeltrick, ne, wo man irgendwie alte Rentner oder also bevorzugsweise
alte Menschen anruft und denen irgendwie einredet, man sei der alte äh längst verloren gegangene Enkel und äh trinkt dann irgendwie einen Kaffee mit denen und sagt am Ende, du, ich brauche mal
Ich brauche mal mein Erbe vorzeitig und dann die Leute eben bedrängt, ähm,
Würde man das über das Internet äh durchführen, per E-Mail, äh dann wäre es eben Cybercrime, ne? Also das heißt, hier wird, hier werden auch traditionelle äh Taten,
oder Verbrechen erfasst und nach meinem Verständnis würde eben auch der Kauf einer ähm,
die die Abhandlung einer Transaktion.
Zum Beispiel einer illegalen äh wahren Transaktion Drogen oder Waffenkauf äh hier dann eben auch äh zu zu Cybercrime äh gehören. Aber da will ich gar nicht so weit ins Detail gehen.
Denn wir bleiben mal bei dieser Sache Darknet. Und zwar war quasi schon angekündigt äh vom
BKA, Darknet wird nochmal ein spezifisches Thema,
bei der bei dieser Pressekonferenz, ne? Das BMI hatte das Thema gesetzt, das BKA hat vorher angekündigt, dass sie das Thema setzen werden und äh entsprechend ähm haben dann natürlich auch die äh die Journalisten dieses Thema.
Schon frühzeitig.
Aufarbeiten können, was ich auch gut finde, weil die Journalisten sich also mal erkundigen konnten, was jetzt dieses Tarknet ist, ne.
Und das auch in vielen Fällen ziemlich gut getan haben.
Ich hatte dann an einen Anruf von der äh von der deutschen Presseagentur, ähm wo ich auch nochmal irgendwie quasi meinen Senf dazu geben durfte und der,
eine Lanze für diese Dark-Web,
Darknet, Darkweb hast du alles nicht gesehen, Technologien, äh, brechen durfte, die dann da ist DPA war auch ähm relativ viel äh Berücksichtigung in der Berichterstattung fand.
Wo warst du überall zu sehen? Tagesschau äh.
Ja primär, also ich hatte da zwei, zwei bis sie Tage, aber es war ähm die ARD hat das dann irgendwie Tagesschau und Nachtmagazin überall reingenommen und Deutschlandradio war ein Interview.
Ist ja nicht gerade irgendwie erst am Morgen irgendwie nach Hause, nach ein paar Tagen was oder nicht.
Das, ich war da gerade ein Tag zu Hause, ja, aber wenn wenn die DPA anruft, dann steht man natürlich gefair bei Fuß.
Ähm ja, das da also das wurde sehr sehr weitflächig rezip rezipiert. Ähm.
Also zumindest ausgestrahlt, ob's rezipiert wurde, ist ja nochmal eine andere Frage.
Ja und also ich genau und dann habe ich war dann schon anderthalb Tage mit mit Presseanfragen und Hintergrundgesprächen und so äh beschäftigt,
Aber auch hier muss ich jetzt hoffentlich ein letztes Mal erklären, was ist denn eigentlich dieses Darknet? Ähm.
Genau. Was ist eigentlich dieses Da.
Ähm so du hast ähm.
Wir haben ja das.
Also vor allem will nochmal kurz einschieben, ne, ich muss auch so ein bisschen grübeln so als auf einmal von Darknet, die Rede so welches damit meint ihr denn jetzt eigentlich? Weil so in meiner Nordsicht.
Ist jetzt zum Beispiel Tor. Nicht stark.
Ähm ja.
Kannst du das gleich nochmal äh äh darstellen, wird es auch dargestellt hast, sondern so. Für mich ist irgendwie da nicht mehr so ein wirkliches äh Konzept eines totalen Underground,
Netzes, was irgendwie parallel zum zum Netz, also sich vielleicht noch darauf stützend, aber eben im Wesentlichen irgendwie komplett mit einer eigenen Logik unterwegs sind. Da gibt es ja auch durchaus technische
Ansätze, so etwas durchzuführen, also nicht nur Ansätze, sondern es gibt auch Realisierung, hat allerdings keine nennenswerte Popularität.
Also der Begriff der Begriff Darknet ist natürlich schon enorm gefärbt. Ja, wir haben äh,
ich glaube in jeder Religion und auch für für Menschen gibt es einfach von früh an.
Die Assoziation Licht ist gut und dunkel ist schlecht. Ja, es gibt dann immer ein paar Leute, die drehen das um und malen sich schwarze Ringe unter die Augen. Ähm aber prinzipiell ist äh der Mensch erstmal im hellen
angenehmer, ne, kommt man besser zurecht, wenn man ähm die entsprechenden äh Sinnesorgane hat, die Assoziation, dass,
dunkel schlecht ist und hell gut oder klar gut die ist einfach schon mal für die für den größeren Teil der Leute drin. Entsprechend ist der Begriff Darknet schon eine eine sehr starke Prägung, was man eben auch da,
wie man das denn zu beurteilen hätte, ne.
Aber nicht vergessen, Storm-Crupper hatten alle weiße Uniformen.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel.
Letzte Frage der Perspektive. Sicher dann auch für die Guten.
Richtig, ne? Und dann äh aber der der Meister von denen da hier der Weder, der war ja auch schwarzer Hanorak wieder, ne.
Stimmt. Aber es wird dran.
Wie dem auch sei. Ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen, dass dieser Begriff Dark äh natürlich schon relativ dark und nett schon so eine ziemlich ziemlich klare Assoziation beim größeren Teil der der Publikums ähm,
hervorruft und die als Darknet bezeichneten Technologien werden ja auch nicht als Darknet propagiert. Es geht ja keiner, der sagt, hi, wir haben hier Darkmet, ne? Super geil, lad runter. Ähm son.
Wovon hier hauptsächlich die Rede war, es gibt verschiedene, derartige Technologien, aber jetzt will ich mal langsam anfangen. Also wir haben Internet
Internet ähm ist ein Netzwerk, sind viele Computer dran angeschlossen und jeder Endpunkt in diesem Netz hat eine IP-Adresse
ja? Dein die Fritzbox hier bei Tim hat eine IP-Adresse im Internet und der metaebene Server im Internet hat auch eine IP-Adresse. Und wenn nun.
Jemand aus dem Internet äh etwas anderes im Internet besuchen will, dann geht dieser Datenstrom mehr oder weniger.
Direkt von der einen IP-Adresse zu der anderen. Das heißt, es ist äh für
für für uns jetzt hier sehr, sehr einfach zu erkennen, dass es die IP-Adresse von äh vom Meterebene-Server und da,
Gehen wir jetzt hin und hören unsere eigenen Podcasts an, ja? Und er wählt da eben der Server sieht auch aha, da ist die IP-Adresse, da schicke ich das hin. Der weiß jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass das die IP-Adresse von Tims zu Hause ist
aber der könnte das herausfinden. Und genauso wissen's auch alle, Vermittlungsstellen, die sich in der Mitte befinden, dass hier gerade das Zuhause von Tim.
Mit dem äh Meterebene Server spricht. Das heißt, es gibt hier keine Maskierung oder Versuche äh irgendwie so zu tun, als wäre,
einer von beiden anonym. Es ist für die beiden an der Kommunikation Beteiligten und auch alle, die diese Kommunikation beobachten oder vermitteln
Klar, wer hier mit wem spricht. Noch dazu? Noch dazu? Da der Meter eben eine Surfer ja kein TLS kann. Können Sie, kann.
Äh die kommunizierten Inhalte sehen. Das heißt, man sieht äh auch welche Por,
der Tim sich dann hier gerade anhört oder hochlädt. So.
Ähm das als Ursprungszustand äh sehend. Jetzt kann man hingehen und sagen, okay, wir verschlüsseln die Kommunikation zwischen diesen beiden.
Zwischen diesen Parteien, indem man eben wie die Jungs von Metronaut hingeht und sagt, okay, wir machen TLS an, dann gibt es also eine verschlüsselte Kommunikation zwischen den beiden. Das heißt.
Die in der Mitte sich befinden.
Vermittlungsstellen und Beobachter können sehen ah der Tim hört gerade seinen Lieblingspodcast, Metro Laut ähm aber die können äh nicht sehen welchen,
ja
Klammer auf, können sie natürlich doch, weil sie sehen, dass er eine Datei bestimmter Größe herunterlädt und Metrolaut nicht so viele Episoden hat, aber äh das sei alles nur geschenkt.
Trotzdem wissen sie, wer da auf wen zugreift und auch wieder beide Positionen wissen äh Werder, äh wer wie die IP-Adresse des anderen ist.
Und dann hat man sich überlegt, okay, jetzt gehen wir doch mal hin und entwickeln eine Technologie mit dem Namen Thor. Äh wie Onian Router.
Und,
da wird das Konzept online, der Zwiebel äh angewendet, indem man sagt, wir machen einfach mehrere Schichten. Wir schicken die Pakete.
Mehrfach hin und her möglichst über die Juristiktionen und Zugriffsgebiete verschiedener Staaten,
Um so den Ursprung des Datenpaketes,
gegenüber dem Empfänger zu maskieren. Üblicherweise oder sehr häufig wird Thor einfach so genutzt, dass man quasi seinen Datentraffic einmal durch Tor durchschleust und dann am Ende doch wieder in
dem normalen Internet rauskommt. Das hieße in dem Falle.
Dass äh wenn wenn Tim jetzt hier den Torbrowser aufmacht und auf Meterebene DE gehe, ähm Meterebene Punkt ME geht, ähm dass,
sein äh dass er die Anfrage an Mieterebene Punkt ME. Im Hintergrund insgesamt mindestens dreimal verschlüsselt wird.
Und zunächst an eine Tor-Entre Note geht, die die erste Verschlüsselung öffnen kann.
Und sieht, aha und und die weiß also aha dieses Paket kommt von Tim. Ich weiß also, dass Tim gerade hier diese Technologie nutzt. Aber alles, was er mir geschickt hat, ist ein weiteres verschlüsseltes Paket,
Und wo ich das hinschicken soll, dann schickt ihr das also an dieses,
an die Mittelnote. Wir sind also jetzt in in zweiten Hobb im Tornetzwerk und die Mittelnord weiß natürlich jetzt nur noch, ah, dieses Paket kommt von einer anderen Note, der Entre Note,
Ich weiß aber nicht, wer es dort abgeliefert hat. Das heißt, die Mittelnot weiß schon nicht mehr, wer Tim ist. Ähm.
So die Theorie. Packt das aus und findet wieder nur ein verschlüsseltes Paket und den nächsten die nächste Note, wo sie es hinschicken soll.
Dann schickt die Mittelnot ist dahin. Diese letzte Not in dem Fall die Exit Note in diesem beschriebenen Fall weiß, macht es auf und kriegt tatsächlich,
Klartext zu sehen, bitte gehe zu Meterebene ME und frage nach der Startseite, ja? Das macht die Exit-Not,
Und die Exit-Note kennt also jetzt die Kommunikationsinhalte, die weiß, äh also bei Meterebene zumindest, weil die ja unverschlüsselt sind. Ähm und weiß also weiß also aha hier möchte jemand die Seite Meterebene ME besuchen.
Sie hat aber keine Ahnung, wer das ist. Und dann geht das ganze Spiel rückwärts, ja?
Die Inhalte sind also ab dem ab der Exit Note, spätestens ab der Exit-Note in Richtung Tim wieder verschlüsset. Das heißt, es gibt in diesem Netz unterwegs.
Die weiß, dass Tim mit der Meterebene kommuniziert und was. Es gibt immer Notes, die Teile davon wissen.
Können.
Aber nicht alles auf einmal.
Mhm.
Und unter der Annahme, dass alle drei Notes von unterschiedlichen Geheimdiensten betrieben werden, ähm kann man so also eine nennenswerte Verschleierung äh des Traffics vornehmen,
Und jetzt geht man hin und sagt, okay, passt doch mal auf. Wenn, warum gehen wir überhaupt am Ende nochmal daraus? Warum sparen wir uns nicht die Exit-Not.
Und bieten in diesem ähm Hin und Hergeschicke,
In diesem verschlüsselten Hin und Hergeschicke sogar Services an. Also wir haben eine Adresse.
Mit der Endung Punkt One.
Und wenn du die aufrufst, das kannst du nur über das Tornetzwerk tun, weil sie nur im Tornetzwerk gerotet wird. Und wenn du das tust, schicken wir das irgendwie, schicken wir diese Anfrage irgendwie bei uns hin und her,
Und irgendwann antwortet einfach eine dieser Notes, weil sie den Dienst selber anbietet. Ähm dann hast du die Situation, dass du quasi nicht nur als.
Client äh das Tornetz nutzen kannst, sondern auch als Server, als Anbieter. Und dort einen hidden Service betreiben kannst. Das heißt, du hast irgendwo einen Server stehen, der hat auch eine IP-Adresse.
Und der ist mit dem Tornetz verbunden und der beantwortet diese verschlüsselten Anfragen,
aber es ist für kaum jemand in diesem Netz nachvollziehbar.
Wer diesen wer diese Note ist, weil er sich genauso verhält wie eine Note einfach nur alles weiterleitet
Und du müsstest also signifikante Bereiche des Tornetzes kontrollieren und äh Trassic Korrelationen machen, um irgendwann wirklich herauszufinden
wo diese Kiste steht. Wir hatten davor vielen Folgen mal drüber gesprochen, wo so der Preis von ähm einer Million US Dollar im Raum stand.
Für einen Angriff, den die Karnegiemellen, Universe University für das FBI implementiert haben soll, äh wenn man bestimmte Sicherheitsannahmen des Tornetzes schwächt, dann geht es auch relativ
fixer, die Idee ist im Prinzip einfach nur.
Es ist nicht trivial herauszufinden, welcher Server diesen Dienst anbietet. Äh man kann das Ganze dann noch unnötig für äh äh man kann das Ganze noch quatsch verkomplexit
Kopf hat komplexieren, indem man den Key einfach wandern lässt, denn jetzt wirst du ja nicht mehr adressiert über eine IP-Adresse,
sondern du wirst adressiert über deine Fähigkeit diese Verschlüsse in Anfragen ähm entschlüsseln und signiert beantworten zu können,
So, zusammengefasst heißt das, man kann im Internet einen Server betreiben.
In der so besuchbar ist, dass Besucher nicht einfach herausfinden können, wo dieser Server tatsächlich steht.
Und entwickelt wurde all das im Kampf gegen Netzüberwachung und Netzzensur.
Das ist der Hintergrund, warum solche Technologien entwickelt wurden. Ich habe das hier auch schon häufiger äh erwähnt. Ähm,
Unter massiver oder unter signifikanter finanzieller Förderung der US-Regierung
die sagt, wir möchten, in Ländern, in denen es keine Meinungsfreiheit gibt, in denen es äh Repressionen gibt für Menschen, die äh ihr Regime kritisieren oder so, die Möglichkeit waren.
Sicher ähm Dienst, Diensttee anzubieten und unzensiert das Netz,
besuchen zu können. Denn dadurch, dass diese Hidden-Services grundsätzlich verschlüsselt kommunizieren und du nicht weißt, wo sie sind.
Kannst du äh den Zugang zu ihnen nicht unterbinden,
Der Tor-Traffic äh sieht immer gleich aus, egal wohin du gehst. Es wird erst auf deinem Rechner vollständig entschlüsselt, das heißt eine zentrale Zensurinstanz sieht nicht
welchen Hidden Service du besuchst, weiß auch nicht, wo sich der befindet und äh weiß auch nicht, welche Inhalte du davon abrufst. Das heißt, es ist enorm schwer.
Diese Torsache in irgendeiner Form zu zensieren. Wie schwer das ist, sieht man am Erfolg,
in China. Selbst äh die äh die große chinesische Firewall, The Golden schielt, wie es China nennt, ist nicht in der Lage, den Zugang zu dem Tornetz vollständig zu unterbinden.
Sie machen's. Teilweise schwer. Da kommen wir jetzt zu technischen Details, die hier glaube ich äh äh über.
Ein wenig über das Ziel hinau.
Wenig wirst du hinausschießen, da könnten wir nochmal eine eine Sendung über Tor im Detail machen, aber.
China gelingt es nicht, den Zugang zu Tor vollständig zu unterbinden. Und das ist, glaube ich, das Entscheidende, der entscheidende Punkt, zu verstehen, ja,
dann wird es dem dem Deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden und Geheimdiensten auch nicht gelingen.
Festzuhalten ist also diese Technologien ermöglichen vollständig anonyme und.
Sagen wir mal praktikabel nicht zu zensierende Kommunikation und in Ländern wie,
fast allen anderen Ländern als Deutschland und den USA ist so etwas für viele Menschen lebensnotwendig, um um um einen politischen Austausch äh aufrechtzuerhalten.
Aber äh es führt eben auch dazu, dass in Ländern wie Deutschland, aber auch in auch in allen anderen Ländern dieser Erde sich natürlich
Kriminelle Angebote in diese
Auf diese Technologien beziehen. Und das ist insbesondere eben bei Silk Road der Fall gewesen, dem ähm sehr bekannten.
Ähm Umschlagsplatz für für hauptsächlich Drogen, aber auch andere äh Produkte und Dienstleistungen.
Und natürlich jetzt vieler äh vieler Nacheiferer in diesem Bereich. Ähm,
Letztendlich sehen diese Seiten aber einfach nur aus wie ganz normale Foren ähm oder Onlinemarktplätze, die eben ein bisschen äh anonymer äh in ihrem Zugriff sind. Haben aber die Gleise der ähnlichen.
Düsseldorf dasselbe.
Ist das Gleiche, sieht aus wie sieht aus wie Internet. Es steht auch nicht, ist auch nicht dunkel und.
Also auch im Dark nicht die Sonnenbrille abnehmen.
Nee, der, also sonst blendet das einfach zu sehr, ne? Ähm.
Gut, also man kann mit einem Hinservice erstmal alles machen, man kann eben dann auch in dem, was Darknet genannt wird, alles machen. Das soll aber nicht heißen, dass es nicht in, dass es eben nicht dort auch eine Menge.
Rechtlich fragwürdige Angebote gibt. So, jetzt kommt.
Viel erklärt.
Viel Erklärt euch, ich bin immer noch nicht fertig.
Jetzt kommt also äh ein Mensch in ein solches Forum und sagt, ich möchte ähm ich hätte gerne eine Knarre. Die kriegen wir die dann.
So, jetzt, jetzt hat er aber natürlich verschiedene Schwierigkeiten. Denn wenn du diese Knarre dann kaufen möchtest, musst du ja immer noch eine Finanztransaktion machen.
Und du musst immer noch eine äh etwas schick.
Kalische Atomtransp.
Immer noch Atome bewegen, ja? Und ähm da kannst du dich natürlich dann auch wieder geschickt oder ungeschickt anstellen.
Na, kannst also sagen, hier einmal Knarre an Linus Neumann. Ähm das äh geht dann in der Regel schief oder da hast du ein großes Risiko, dass das schief geht. Deswegen,
kauft man dann in der Regel so gehackte DHL-Boxen oder so was, ne? Oder bestellt das an an Wohnungen, die irgendwie vielleicht gerade leerstehen oder sonst was. Man hat also noch weitere, größere, logistische Herausforderungen. Die Transaktion dann am Ende wirklich durchzuführen.
Ähm,
Und man hat durch die Anonymität die vollständige Anonymität des Anbieters natürlich auch ein großes Risiko dem zu trauen.
Was eben äh dann auch so Treuhanddienste notwendig macht. Das war eben das, womit auch Silkroad sehr gut,
am Ende Geld verdient hat, dass sie ihm gesagt haben, okay, die Bitcoins gehen erstmal auf uns als Treuhänderkonto und erst wenn der Empfänger den Empfang bestätigt,
geht das Geld an den Anbieter, ja? Ähm, du hast aber natürlich trotzdem das Problem, wie traust du denn deinem Anbieter,
Äh Silquat hat das dann gelöst mit so einem Bewertungssystem, ähnlich wie eBay das in den neunziger Jahren gemacht hat, gesagt, okay, äh klar, du weißt nicht, ob jemand dir am Ende hier den.
Porzellanpuppe auch wirklich schickt. Deswegen, wenn er den nicht schickt, dann schreibst du eben hin, habe ich nicht bekommen, äh Betrüger. Ja und eBay hat dann gesagt, okay, dann machen wir PayPal. Da kriegst du dann sogar noch Versicherungen für die durch Transaktion, kriegst das Geld zurück, ja?
Ähm nur wenn alle Akteure dort.
Anonym sind und nirgendwo eine feste Verbindung haben, kannst du dir natürlich ohne Probleme zwanzig Accounts machen.
Die alle bei deinem einundzwanzigsten Account angeblich eine Knarre kaufen und sagen top Knarre gerne wieder. Und ähm.
Das haben natürlich auch für verschiedene Dienstleistungen und Produkte äh die Strafverfolgungsbehörden getan. Äh insbesondere bei Silk Road, der Fall äh Silk Road endete damit, dass.
Einer der Administratoren oder einer Account der Administratoren eine,
Ermordung in Auftrag geben wollte
Das Angebot der Ermordung wurde aber dort selber vom FBI äh angeboten. Das heißt, das FBI ist da drin und nutzt die Anonymität genauso wie alle anderen auch und sagt hier Auftragsmord für fünf Bitcoin äh bringe ich äh fünf, fünf gi.
Das Angebot kam vom FBI damals.
Natürlich, so haben die den Typen bekommen, dass FBI hat dann äh so und das ist, es ist auch, es ist auch klug, dass sie das machen
denn wenn du wenn du jemanden um die Ecke bringen willst, musst du ja früher oder später sagen, so heißt die Person und da wohnt die,
Und dann setzt das FBI sich ins Auto, fährt dahin und sagt, Entschuldigung, wir wollten nur kurz Bescheid sagen. Ihnen trachtet jemand nach dem Leben. Und wir machen jetzt Folgendes. Wir haben hier so eine Polaroid-Kamera und eine Flasche Ketchup.
Und wir machen jetzt mal kurz ein Foto.
Und sie tauchen mal eine Woche unter und dann schicken wir das zurück und kassieren die Bitcoins. Klar, FBI muss ja auch irgendwo Schwarzgeld herkriegen. Nein, haben die natürlich.
Haben die natürlich,
Haben die in dem Fall natürlich aus einem anderen Grund gemacht, weil sie äh inkriminierendes äh für für den Auftraggeber haben wollten. Die wollten den Beweis haben, dass der nicht, dass der diesen Mord in Auftrag gegeben hat.
Und bereitest sogar dafür bezahlen.
Und den auch bezahlt hat.
Äh das ist passiert, dass es zweimal passiert in diesem Falle. Und am Ende hat das FBI dann durch verschiedene andere,
groß aufwendige Methoden. Ähm am Ende einen Menschen in einer ähm öffentlichen Bibliothek verhaftet, der quasi eingeloggt war am Silkroade Admin Interface,
Ja? Also die haben den.
In Flagranti.
In Flagan Fagi Flagranti auf frischer Tat ertappt, wie er sich dort eingeloggt hat. Ähm.
Schilder das nur, um mal zu sagen, wie eben so wie eben so in diesem Darknet Ermittlungserfolge funktionieren,
Ähm denn was du natürlich auch wunderschön machen kannst, ist, du schickst also deine, ne, bestellt einer eine Knarre und du schickst einfach ein Paket los.
Ähm,
mit einem GPS-Tracker und in dem Moment, wo das in der Packstation ist, äh hast du dann Zivilpolizisten auf der Bank daneben sitzen und der, der sich die Knarre aus der Parkstation holt. Zack, äh, Handschellen, ne? So, so, so,
Kriegst du eben diese Ermittlungserfolge und das ist, wenn ich das mal hier vorsichtig anmerken darf, einfacher.
Als wenn du äh versuchst den den illegalen Waffenhandel, der ja seit Jahrzehn,
Auf dieser Erde stattfindet, äh auf dem richtigen Schwarzmarkt versuchst zu kontrollieren. Das war das, was ich auch allen äh Journalisten immer äh ins Heft diktiert habe. Der Handel mit Waffen, der Handel mit Drogen sind,
Phänomene, die sehr viel älter sind als das Darknet und außerhalb des Darknet auch sehr viel verbreiteter. Das darf man hier
An dieser Stelle wirklich nicht ähm vergessen. Und jetzt kann ich endlich, was ich schon immer machen wollte, hier mal den Film,
Dieb Web empfehlen, den ich durch Zufall letztens gesehen habe.
Den kriegt man äh auf an den üblich bekannten äh Vorverkaufsstellen, also Netflix und Piratebay. Ähm da,
der das ist eine Dokumentation über den Fall von Russ Ulbricht ähm der als Betreiber von.
Silk Road äh jetzt eingekerkert wurde. Ähm und dem auch diese unter anderem diese Auftrags ähm Rödel zu Last gelegt werden. Wobei es große,
gute Gründe für Zweifel daran gibt, dass er auch tatsächlich das war. Ähm.
Jetzt komme ich vom vom Hundertstel aufs Tausendste, aber das erkläre ich auch noch kurz. Und zwar war es so, dass der Administrator,
die Personadministrator von Silk Road, äh Dread Pirote Roberts hieß. Und das ist eine fiktive Figur aus einem äh Buch oder Film. Buch und oder Film, die immer mehrere Personen waren. Also,
du kannst Grad Paradrobets dahin fahren, etwas, was du weitergegeben hast an unterschiedliche Personen. Und es gibt also Grund
Zu der Annahme des Silkroade nicht nur von einer Person administriert wurde, sondern von mehreren,
Und dass das FBI am Ende nur eine davon erwischt hat, dieser Person aber alles äh zur Last gelegt hat. Ähm das wird in diesem Fall in diesem äh Film,
sehr gut behandelt und er vor allem werden da auch sehr schön dargestellt die Ideologien, die Menschen haben, die solche unzensierte.
In unsensierten, freien Handel propagieren, ne? Ähm, also durchaus eine Empfehlung, sich das mal,
sich diesen Film mal äh anzuschauen.
Link ist in den Shore-Notes, wie sich das gehört.
Ja gut, also wir fassen äh kurz zusammen.
Da mag oder mag nicht, sich jemand unter Zuhilfenahme äh eines oder des Darknetz des Tornetzes oder eines anderen Netzes eine Waffe äh beschafft haben, das hat offensichtlich,
lange funktioniert, das ist mitnichten so, dass äh diese Methode als besonders effizient oder besonders anonym bekannt wäre und dass man
darüber jetzt auf einmal einen Fluss von Waffen herstellen könnte, der so im normalen Leben nicht existiert, ganz im Gegenteil, es gibt natürlich äh einen einen kriminellen
Bereich in unserer Gesellschaft, auch jenseits des Netzes, in dem äh sehr wohl solche Transaktionen stattfinden, auch in Deutschland, außerhalb dort in Deutschland natürlich ohnehin, also es gi
Länder da gibt's ganze ganze Regionen, wo man einfach hinfährt, Grenzbereiche, Grenzgebiete,
wie so in Afrika irgendwie aus.
Der Ferne äh mitbekommen. Also es es gibt keinen Mangel an an Nachschub. Natürlich ist es in unserem Verhältnismäßig stark regulierten,
Gesellschaft in Deutschland wünschenswert, das so weit einzuschränken, wie es nur irgendwie geht. Ähm, wir haben irgendwie überhaupt relativ viele Waffen doch noch in,
in Deutschland und mag immer so glauben, es es wäre so schrecklich wenig, ist nur so, dass eben die Leute, die eben Waffen haben,
dann entsprechend über Waffenscheine verfügen und in entsprechende Auflagen erfüllen müssen, die ja jetzt so gering auch nicht sind, aber im Bereich der Kriminalität gibt's natürlich einfach diesen Flow und wer irgendwie eine Waffe äh bekommen will,
der hat auch die Möglichkeit dazu.
Hello Iking Get you to by free Clock this of the noon. With Nail Polish. Ähm.
Ja, so viel, so viel zum Darknet. Ähm man kann also sagen, wenn wir jetzt dieses Darknet, also wir kriegen es eh nicht weg.
Und wenn wir's äh wegkriegen würden, würden wir damit weder den Drogen noch den Waffenhandel signifikant eindämmen, aber eben die,
Möglichkeit äh anonym und äh sicher im Internet zu kommunizieren und diese Möglichkeit ist eben auch für viele,
für viele Menschen überall auf der Erde sehr wichtig
Interessanterweise, ich glaube, in der zwanzig Uhr Tagesschau oder in der, ich weiß nicht, die, die ARD-Redaktion hat den Beitrag öfter so ein bisschen unterschiedlich geschnitten, aber an einer Stelle
war das dann
wurde quasi nach meinem Zitat, wo ich irgendwie sagte, so ja und so weiter, viele Menschen brauchen das. Äh war dann dieser die der Sprecher. Da möchte auch der BKA-Präsident gar nicht widersprechen
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, den haben wir schon mal ganz gut eingeritten, den Herrn Münch, ja,
Ähm ansonsten geht mal ins Darknet und äh guckt mal, was es da so an an Austausch und Möglichkeiten gibt. Ähm.
Nicht alles dort ist äh schrecklich, nicht alles dort ist illegal und vor allem äh wenn euch da jemand
Knarren oder Ermordung oder sonstige komische Dienstleistungen wie Randhacker anbietet dann seht ihr könnt ihr den BKA und dem FBI live bei der Arbeit zuschauen.
Ja
Dann gab's noch also vielleicht noch kurz am Rande, dann gab's irgendwie so eine äh gab's natürlich wieder, das haben Netzpolitik Orkan schön aufgearbeitet, irgendwie schöne schöne schönes Malen nach Zahlen. Äh wir Karsten.
Meier wird Leiter der Abteilung Cybercrime
beim BKA hatte vor einem Jahr schon behauptet, dass bis zu einer Million Menschen in Deutschland illegale Einkäufe im Darknet tätigen würden. Ähm da kommentierte Netzpolitik Orksschön, ja, wir wir fänden, wir für uns wäre es eine
eine Wahnsinnsmeldung, wenn überhaupt eine Million Menschen Tor nutzen würden in Deutschland, ja? Das ist also durchaus.
War geil.
Die Zahl war ganz geil. Ähm zum Vergleich Facebook
Facebook bietet auch äh sein, seinen Dienst als Hit und Service an. Die zählen eine Millionen Nutzer weltweit, ja? Oder die sagen also bis zu eine Million Menschen haben schon mal Facebook über über Dark eine Technologien genutzt.
Ähm das halte ich dann für eine realistischere Zahl. Ähm,
Und dann sagen sie, gibt's auch irgendwie eine Grafik, die sich auf eine Studie von zweitausenddrei bezieht, wo gesagt wird, dass Deep-Web seit zehn bis hundert Mal größer als der Service-Web?
Und das ist also eine Studie von zweitausenddrei, wo man so eine schöne ähm Eisberganalogie
herbeigezogen hat. Da geht aber da ist aber der Begriff Deepweb quasi das was es von Suchmaschinen indiziert
Und dann wird gesagt, nur ein kleiner Teil ist von Zoommaschinen initiiert und es gibt was wir als Internet wahrnehmen, ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Äh das sind alles so, ich werde das jetzt so,
Bauernfänger, Visualisierung, Bauernfängerargumente, Bauernfänger, Bullshit. Also sorry, ich meine
Du kennst das, was du als, was dir hier die Augen öffnet, ist so die Spitze des Eisbären. Da drunter ist runter, da und Unterwasser natürlich, ne? Unter Wasser, tief, da unten ist noch viel mehr und was sich da alles herumtreibt an Kriminellen
na ja das davor sei gewarnt. Jetzt haben wir gerade lange genug über dieses äh Darkbett gesprochen,
So, jetzt mal aufs anderes.
Ja andere dunkle Bereiche äh spielen sich ja gerade ab. Bei der Berek.
Das ist doch nicht dunkel, da ey Berig macht gerade paar Excellence, ey. Ja, richtig Surf ist.
Surfice-Web. Ja, da werden auf jeden Fall die ähm die Flussbä
neu eingemessen, wie denn irgendwie auf dieser Oberfläche die Daten zu laufen haben. Wir haben ja schon mehrfach darüber berichtet zu unser aller Entsetzen hat sich ja die europäische Union
Also das Parlament für Regelung, also nicht nur das Parlament, sondern die Kommission und im Rahmen des Trilogs natürlich dann auch der Rat, sprich die Union hat sich eben auf eine Neuregelung der Netzneutralität im,
Netz oder erstmalig wirklichen Regelungen der Netzneutralität ähm zusammengefunden und.
Leider einen Weg eingeschlagen, den man als bedauerlich bezeichnen muss, nachdem die USA ja noch
kurz vor Schluss die Kurve bekommen haben, ist dies in Europa nicht gelungen und die Formulierung, die in dem Abschlussdokument zu finden sind, sind sehr fraglich gewesen
nun äh ist es aber so, dass das eben nur erstmal ein schwammiger Gesetzestext ist, dass es um die konkrete technische Umsetzung geht, beziehungsweise um die konkreten
Regulationsvorschriften, die letzten Endes für die Telekommunikationsprovider in Europa
gelten die am Ende bestimmen, wie es denn nun mit der Netzneutralität aussieht oder nicht. Und das ist wiederum,
Aufgabe einer europäischen Regulierungsbehörde, der Berek und diese Berek hat nun in den letzten Wochen sich getroffen, die ganze Zeit eigentlich in Wien oder haben sie da nur angefangen? Ich weiß es nicht ganz genau.
Auf jeden Fall waren diese Konsultationen ähm am Laufen und sie wurden
begleitet äh unter anderem im Netz
Internet, dot EU-Mut, was wir schon mehrfach äh angesprochen haben, wo Thomas Luniger unter anderem sehr äh aktiv ist, der ja hier immer wieder mal berichtet und präsent ist
und ja, die Aufforderung,
hier ein Kommentar äh einzureichen. Dem sind relativ viele Leute nachgegangen, je nachdem wie man jetzt glauben mag, äh es ist eine Zahl knapp über oder knapp
unter fünfhunderttausend,
im Vergleich zu sonstigen Direktkonsultationen, wo öffentliche Kommentare eingefordert werden oder ermöglicht sind, äh was sich so in der Größenordnung von vielleicht hundert Kommentaren.
Bei Berek war hundert.
Okay, also der Rekord lag bei hundert
Der ist jetzt definitiv eingestellt worden. Wir wissen natürlich jetzt nicht, äh was der Inhalt dieser einzelnen Kommentare war, aber ich denke, wir können mal davon ausgehen, dass jetzt hier im Wesentlichen äh gefordert wurde, doch diese Auslegung der Regeln möglichst so zu gestalten
das Schlimmste noch verhindert werden kann.
Also safe the Internet dot you äh sagt äh fünfhundertundzehntausenddreihundertsiebzig Einreichungen, die Berek sagt, sie habe insgesamt,
fast eine halbe Million erreicht, also was unter Umständen ist ein Teil von Safety Internet äh Einreichung dort dann bei der Berick äh im Spam gelandet oder so. Ähm,
Aber ist auf jeden Fall wurde hier sehr klar dokumentiert, dass es ein massives Interesse äh der äh der Gesellschaft an diesem Bereich gibt,
Ja, also wenn du normalerweise,
in der Regel nicht mehr als hundert kriegst und du hast auf einmal eine halbe Million da liegen, äh dann wird dir sehr klar verdeutlicht ähm.
Wie es hier läuft. Man kann da jetzt auch nur echt nochmal Thomas loben, ja? Der also er steckt ja hinter diesem äh,
safe net new trailty, safety Internet und dem ganzen, den ganzen Spielereien und hat eben
Er hat ja damals gesagt, als diese Triloggeschichte zu Ende war, hat er gesagt, jetzt äh ist der Kampf nicht verloren, sondern jetzt geht er los. Und äh
dann wenn es dann losgeht mit äh da gibt's eine Beere-Konsultation und so, das sind echt keine Themen, die sexy zu verkaufen sind, ne
Und wenn du aber das dann hinkriegst, eine halbe Million Leute dazu zu bringen, ihren ihren Kram dazu zu geben. Das ist äh,
ein Erfolg, der weit äh über das hinausgeht, was äh ich mir für vorstellbar gehalten habe. Also echt herzlichen Glückwunsch,
dazu und tiefen, tiefen Respekt auch für die Leistung. Für alle an alle Beteiligten.
Fragt sich natürlich, was jetzt dabei rauskommt und inwiefern in diese Bierkonsultation, diese äh Kommentare auch konkret äh eingehen werden. Das ist noch nicht klar.
Fünfhunderttausend Kommentare und ein großes Awach.
Ja ja ihr seid alle dafür, dass wir das anders machen, aber
haben wir ja nicht gerechnet. Man sollte sich, glaube ich, nicht zu viele Hoffnungen machen, denn am Ende ist ja der Gesetzestext schon mal eine schlechte Vorgabe, das heißt in irgendeiner Form muss das Ganze ähm ja,
Darauf hinaus laufen Ausnahmeregelungen zu äh schaffen, also Spezialdienste wie das so schön heißt. Ähm.
Ich kann das schwer einschätzen, inwiefern da ähm wie die Endergebnisse da aussehen werden.
Ja. Wir werden es erleben.
Sehr schwer sind auch die Endergebnisse abzusehen in der Türkei.
Ah
Das ist auch wieder so ein großes Seufz. Wir werden jetzt aber nicht die ganze Putschgeschichte erzählen, oder?
Nee, ich fälle mir eigentlich ein, dass dass die haben wirklich lange keine Sendung mehr gemacht. Jetzt ich jetzt wirker quasi. Das war nämlich der war ITF in Berlin.
Nur drei Wochen.
Zu der Zeit, ähm da wollte ich eigentlich auch noch ein bisschen was von erzählen, aber denn da schafft man nicht mehr in dieser Sendung, habe ich auch nicht vorbereitet. Ich hätte noch ein bisschen von der ITF erzählen können, aber okay. Ähm.
Irgendwann Abends bekam ich eine Putschnotifikation auf mein Handy. Ähm.
So der äh ja sowas. Ähm.
Es gab es gab also ein ähm es kam als.
Ein kleiner Teil des äh des türkischen Militärs äh sah sich äh bemüßigt ein ein Putsch in der Türkei durchzuführen. Das ist in der Türkei nichts besonderes. Das ist dort schon öfter vorgekommen. Ähm.
Aber schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Ja, also alle fünfzehn, zwanzig Jahre oder so, ne? Hast du das, glaube ich, in der Türkei. Äh die in der Türkei sieht sich das Militär stärker.
Als ähm Hüter der äh kemalistischen Verfassung, also äh,
Mustafa Kemal, Atatürk hat ja die Türkei als einen und das finde ich sehr besonders, weil da das ist eine Sache, die die Türkei Deutschland voraus hat, als einen stark lazistischen Staat
definiert. Wo gesagt wird, okay, äh Religion und Staat sind hier bitteschön stark und
äh streng getrennt zu halten. Das haben wir in Deutschland nicht unbedingt. Bei uns treibt der Staat für die Kirchen sogar Steuern ein. Ähm,
Aber die sonstigen politischen Verhältnisse der Türkei sind natürlich beklagenswert. Insofern hielt ich es auch zunächst für eine sehr gute Nachricht, äh dass der Regentschaft von äh.
Erdogan an dieser Stelle ein Ende gesetzt werden würde. Ähm,
Ist aber nicht so gekommen, die der Putsch wurde relativ kam relativ schnell zu einem Ende.
Mit einigen sehr blutigen, gewaltsamen Auseinandersetzungen ähm da sich offenbar selbst die politischen Gegner, Erdogans ähm,
gegen äh diesen Putsch aussprachen, deren Motivation war mir äh und ist mir auch nach wie vor nicht ganz klar. Ähm das ist aber auch hier nicht Logbuch,
ähm.
Bosporus Politik. Äh deswegen ähm nehme ich das einfach mal zur Kenntnis, dass es diese Vorkommnisse in der Türkei gab und dass daraufhin ähm Erdogan einem.
Eine Reihe an,
Maßnahmen ergriffen hat, die also wirklich über alles Vorstellbare hinausgeht, ne? Also irgendwie hat irgendwie am nächsten Tag schon irgendwie eine Liste von so und so viel tausend Richtern gehabt, die ihres Amtes enthoben werden, hat äh den die intellektuellen des Landes mit einem Reiseverbot
belegt hat, danach fünfundzwanzig,
Tausend oder also irgendwelche riesigen Zahlen an staatlich bediensteten im Bereich der Erziehung entlassen und der macht jetzt da das, was man.
Fünfzehntausend Dekane und äh Führer von Universitäten eine unfassbare äh Dimension an an Säuberung und.
Die Ersäuberungen nennt, ja? Also.
Auch noch Säuberung nennt und und das ist sozusagen äh ja absurd. Also es ist es ist äh es ist im Prinzip der doppelte Putsch,
Also es wurde
ich glaube diesen Verschwörungstheorien, er hätte diesen Putsch von vornherein gestartet, äh kann man glaube ich nicht so viel angehen, was durchaus vorstellbar ist, dass er in irgendeiner Form gewarnt war.
Wenn man sich anschaut, wie elegant äh wie schnell das Ganze äh äh überworfen wurde, ne. Also da gab es zumindest nicht den notwendigen äh Rückhalt und jetzt gibt es aber auf jeden Fall keinen nennenswerten Widerstand.
Gegen diese Maßnahmen, das Ganze wird halt noch begleitet mit drei Monate Ausnahmezustand, in der ohnehin alles geregelt werden kann. Also das Ganze ist im Kern der Untergang
der Türkei ist Renote, da wird jetzt glaube ich kein Stein mehr auf dem äh anderen bleiben und es ist auch vollkommen unklar
diese Situation jemals wieder reversiert werden soll, man muss halt schauen, welche Auswirkungen das jetzt auf die Türkei hat,
also gerade in wirtschaftlicher Hinsicht, wenn man sich Tourismus anschaut ist äh ist schon mal relativ dramatisch, davon wird er sich sicherlich alleine nicht äh bremsen lassen. Man kennt das, es ist eigentlich
Eigentlich ist das alles so vorhersehbar und alles so äh schon mal da gewesen, dass es eigentlich nur noch traurig ist, dass so ein Land, was eigentlich schon sich auch.
Wie soll ich sagen, schon so ein modernes Gesellschaftswesen gegeben hatte über die Zeit noch in der Lage ist, so sehr in so einem Sumpf zu versinken und jetzt,
sich im Prinzip aller Perspektiven beraubt.
Also genau, der Mann macht dieses Land jetzt richtig kaputt,
Also der schadet der Türkei massiv in in wirtschaftlichen Bereichen, in also natürlich primär wirtschaftlichen Bereichen, aber eben auch in den gesellschaftlichen Bereichen. Das ist richtig richtig, richtig,
Schlimm was da passiert. Aber dieser Mensch, Erdogan war schon immer schlimm,
Ja, also ich meine, ich habe meine äh ich glaube, das hatte ich hier im Logbuch auch mal kurz erwähnt, dass ich ja auch mal von Erdogans Schergen.
Angegriffen wurde mit Tränengas und Blendgranaten und Wasserwerfern mit äh mit so Reizmitteln drin. Also ist so richtig ähm
Das war also bei der, bei der Räumung des äh Gesi-Parks, wo ich das äh unglücklicherweise zu dem Zeitpunkt gerade drin war. Ähm.
Das war äh also der Mann ist einfach irre, ne? Also das ist ein ein wahnsinniger
Gewaltherrscher mit wir haben ja vor wenigen Wochen und Monaten noch in Deutschland allein schon gesehen, wir gegen Deutsche ähm gegen deutsche Comedy oder oder Satire vorgeht,
also absolut wahnsinnig und es gibt ist es.
Das Gebot für jeden äh sich sich diesen Menschen irgendwie zu widersetzen und es wird irgendwann bald nicht mehr gehen, weil er das ganze Land in in den Zwängen seiner äh seiner Gewalt hat und ähm,
ärgerlicherweise hat dieser Putsch das Ganze nur ähm verschlimmert. Nun,
Warum ist das für uns im Logbuch Netzpolitik interessant? Natürlich, weil er da irgendwie rumzensiert wie ein Irrer in diesem Internet, das ist aber auch nichts Neues. Ähm
Quasi mit diesem Putsch kündigte äh Wiki liegt's dann an, ja wir werden äh Standby for Release, wir hauen jetzt hier bald die AKP-Mails raus und dann geht's echt rund hier, dann fliegt dem Erdogan aber der Löcher aus dem Käse,
Das halten sie eine Tage vorher, äh also einige Tage vorher angekündigt und dann äh twitterte der Wiki Leaks Twitter Account ähm.
Die ganze Zeit nur noch irgendwas von ja und das Sustain Cyber Attack,
irgendwie du stellst dir diesen armen Menschen in dieser Botschaft vor. Der hat da irgendwie offenbar echt so seinen Cyberware geführt, weil er, ich meine, weil du ankündigst, du kündigst an, wir werden,
weiß ich nicht. Die E-Mails der AKP, also der der Erdogan-Partei äh releasen. Dann wunderst du dich, dass deine Seite sofort in der Türkei
ist und dass du irgendwie einen ordentlichen Detox abkriegst, kannst ja nun wirklich, also ich ich frage mich auch wirklich, ob der irgendwie ob der langsam dement wird da oder so, aber da komme ich gleich nochmal zu.
Ja, zumal ihr sicher sozusagen auch gar nicht um das handelt, was sie gesagt haben, was es ist.
Genau, denn am Ende released, also es geht so Wiki-Leaks, Release, dann diese E-Mails und das war irgendwie weiß ich nicht wieder irgend so eine fantastische Zahl und dann sagen sie irgendwie, ja und hier ist ganz viel,
in den E-Mails, die sind natürlich alle türkisch, ja? Äh in den, in den E-Mails steht ganz viel über Güllen
Und äh oder Gülen, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man den ausspricht. Das ist der sich im amerikanischen Exil befindliche
Nemesis von Erdogan, dem der dem dieser Putsch auch jetzt sofort in die Schuhe geschoben wurde und das heißt aber auch äh Lachen,
Ja, also das heißt, in diesen E-Mails steht relativ oft äh Güllen drin,
Äh und weil die über irgendwas lachen, weil die sich halt freuen, fröhliche Menschen, ja? Und Vicky liegt dann so, ja, hier, guck mal, was die alles über Göllen sagen. Wir haben das jetzt mal hier gedammt. So.
Einschließlich suche danach und so, also. Ja. Also mit anderen Worten, hier wurde ein Dampf rausgebracht, dessen Inhalt von denjenigen, die das,
vermutlich auf den Weg gebracht haben in die Öffentlichkeit gebracht haben, nicht wirklich analysiert wurde. Es wurde nicht wirklich äh drüber geschaut, was ist dieser Inhalt? Es wurde in irgendeiner Form
nahegelegt, dass es sich hierbei um die E-Mails der AKP handelt, wahrscheinlich so in dieser Erwartungshaltung, dass wenn man irgendwie da reinschaut, dass man schon irgendwie finden würden, wie sie da alle die Konspirationen, einen Putsch und so weiter aushandeln. Äh
Tatsächlich handelt es sich aber hier mehrheitlich offenbar,
nicht, dass ich die gelesen hätte. Ähm mehr um Mails an die AKP,
also mehr sozusagen eine eine Inbox als ein äh umfangreicher Austausch von äh AKP-Aktivisten,
Und so eine ganz nebenbei äh enthielten diese Mails auch noch andere Daten. Nein.
Nee, erhielten sie nicht. Ähm das waren erstmal nur die Mails und jetzt passierte folgendes. Der Hacker, der diese Daten ähm.
Organisiert hat von der AKP. Ähm übrigens wird gesagt, es es handelte sich dabei um Finees, Fischer
Oder Finnes, Fischer, das ist derjenige oder das Pseudonym der Person, die schon äh Gamma gehackt hat und Hacking-Team
also echt jemand der eins nach dem anderen wirklich High Value Targets richtig,
und der auch schon früher seine Solidarität mit äh der kurdischen Bewegung kundgetan hat. Insofern ist es noch nicht mal
unwahrscheinlich, dass es sich tatsächlich um Finez Fischer handelt, ja? Der das getan hat.
Der hat also diese AK, diese AKP Server äh aufgemacht, hat die Sachen an Wiki Leaks geschickt und hat Wiki Leaks gesag.
Wartet mal bitte mit dem Release. Ich bin da noch drin und hole mehr raus. Wiki Leaks hat aber äh
hat das aber dann diesen Tweet auf dessen,
In dessen Folge sie dann eben gesperrt wurden und Detox bekamen, haben eben sofort damit angegeben, wir haben jetzt hier AKP Kram
Das führte aber natürlich dazu, dass der Finess Fischer, der irgendwo in diesen AKP-Servern noch am Runterladen war. Damit rechnen musste, dass da sein Zugang bald weg ist, ja?
Dann befand sich Wiki Leaks eben unter Dedos und haben da ihren AKP League angekündigt und keiner konnte darauf zugreifen.
Und dann sagte dieser Finez Fischer, okay, ich mache jetzt einfach mal einen Torent mit allem, was ich da rausgeholt habe,
Und hat einen Tourent bereitgestellt, mit äh.
Wem, allen.
Stellst du immer den gesamten Internet bereit.
Die Frage, wem du den Link äh.
Öffentlich. Der hat einen Text verfasst, wo er gesagt hat, hier, das ist geschehen. Hier sind meine Daten, hier ist der Trown viel Spaß.
Dieser Torent ähm enthielt dann noch mehr Dateien. Und es war dann so, dass eine äh Person, ich glaube Michael Best oder so hieß der, diesen Torent,
in das Internet Arkave hochgeladen hat. Den kompletten Inhalt des Torens.
Und Wiki Leaks hat dann dorthin verlinkt. Und hat gesagt, hier sind auch nochmal Dan. So, das heißt, dieser komplett diese kompletten Daten.
Zirkulierten jetzt uns offen, frei und zensiert als Torent und der und einer hat es eben dann auch nochmal auf dem Internet AK öffentlich auf einem durchsuchbaren Service zugänglich gemacht und Wiki Leaks hat drauf gelingt,
Derjenige, der den Torin veröffentlicht hat, sagt, ähm also der den Torenther ins Internet, Arkave hochgeladen hat, sagt.
Ich habe mir die Inhalte nicht vorher nochmal genau angeschaut, weil ähm einige Teile dieser Dateien waren ja eh schon released worden durch Weki-Leaks, dann habe ich gedacht, okay, den Rest kann ich ja auch nochmal kurz dat aufhauen.
Ärgerlicherweise befanden sich unter den Dateien ähm,
Eine Liste der Wahlberechtigten Frauen in neunundsiebzig von einundachtzig.
Bezirken der Türkei.
Also fast alles.
Mit aktuellen Daten und in einer in einem Land, in dem gerade Säuberungen stattfinden. Ich meine, die AKP-Anhänger haben ja auch.
Nur das auch noch mit mit einem Fleck, ob sich dabei irgendwie um AK-Anhänger handelt.
Ob's sich's um AKP-Anhänger handelt oder nicht, ja. Und in einem Land, in dem gerade ein Kuhgescheitert ist und ich meine AKP-Anhänger haben auch in Deutschland randaliert, ne. Die sind,
Ähm die sind jetzt alles andere als friedlich,
Kann man auch verstehen, der Putsch hat glaube ich auch so einen Def Tool von, der Putschversuch hat den Destolf von über zweihundert Menschen. Ähm insofern kann man.
Ähm insofern kann man.
Ist nachvollziehbar, dass AKP-Anhänger da jetzt ähm.
Ungehalten reagieren und es kommt ja eben zu allerlei gewaltsamen Auseinandersetzungen ähm
Und da ist natürlich so ein, so ein League aktueller Daten für allerlei, für alle allein Menschen äh eine nichts besonders Gutes noch dazu, wenn es sich eben, ja, einfach mal, sagen wir mal, um
sicher nicht mehr als fünfundneunzig Prozent der Frauen in der Türkei handelt. Wenn du jetzt einfach mal vorstellst.
In in Deutschland, wo es jetzt keinen Putsch gab, wären auf einmal Namen und aktuelle Namen und Adressen von
Weiß nicht, den größten Teil der weiblichen Bevölkerung zugänglich, dann kannst du dir vorstellen, was das für allerlei Stalker, Kriminelle und sonstige
Arschlöcher bedeutet, wenn sie Zugriff auf diese Daten haben, ja? Das heißt, da sind also jetzt eine ganze Menge Menschen.
In Gefahr aufgrund dieses nicht beabsichtigten, aber trotzdem vorgekommenen,
Dingens, Dinges. Und dann formulierte ähm eine,
Autorin mit dem ich kann den Namen leider sehr schwäch schwer aussprechen, ich versuch's aber,
eine äh Professorin an der School of Information and Library Science in der University of North Carolina. Äh ein Text auf Wiki Leagues äh auf auf Wiki Leaks äh in der Huffington Post, wo sie also sagte hier, das ist äh Wiki League, hat hier Menschen in Gefahr gebracht. Es gibt kein
Grund dafür. Ähm! Und dann wurde sie irgendwie von Wiki Leaks bedroht,
Also Wiki-Deaks twitterte dann irgendwie so äh Stop, hör auf hier so zu lügen äh sonst äh zeigen wir dich an oder so oder auch denkst du was soll denn der Mist? Ähm,
dann kritisierte ähm.
Snowden, das mit einem Tweet und sagte jetzt, den versuche ich mal gerade ganz kurz äh öffentlich. Da sagte der Mock-Resising, Information, Head never, bin more Vital,
der Hostility to even Modes Curation Isamy Stake. Äh also er sagt, die Demokratisierung der Information war niemals wichtiger als heute und Wiki League hat dabei geholfen, aber deren Feindseligkeit gegen so
gegen auch nur moderates Kuratieren der Veröffentlichung ist ein Fehler.
Ähm daraufhin antwortete Wiki Leaks.
Ähm ich übersetze es direkt auf Deutsch. Opportunismus wird dir keine Begnadigung verdienen von Clinton? Ähm.
Kuratierung heißt nicht die Zensierung der Cashflows, der der herrschenden Parteien. Also jetzt hat jetzt hat Wiki Leaks sich auch noch mit mit Snowden angelegt. Ähm es ist wirklich ähm.
Wenn ich nochmal übersetzen darf, was die Leaks zu Snoten gesagt hat, fuck you.
Ja und sie haben sie haben ihm gesagt, du bist ein Opportunist und du, du, du, du sagst es nur, weil du von Clinton begnadigt werden möchtest. Also es ist wirklich.
Also die die also Wikilix der Paranoia Level ist wirklich extrem hoch.
Wikicks hat nein, das ist nicht der Paranoia Level ist hoch, sondern der Typ, der dreht durch. Und ähm ja, es,
Es ist auch noch, dann gab's noch diesen Fall, den.
Ähm Twitter hat irgendwie sehr lange ähm einen sehr bekannten.
Ähm ja, er wird als Treu bezeichnet, aber ich bin ja der der Überzeugung, dass solche Menschen als Treu zu bezeichnen, eine Schande für jeden Troll ist. Also ein ein Hater, der die ganze Zeit auf,
Twitter, allerlei Menschen einfach niederträchtig beleidigt hat. Und zwar seit Jahren. Das war der Account äh Nero at Nero und der gehörte einem Milo so und so,
und der war irgendwie bekannt, äh dafür, dass er eben einfach ein Arschloch ist. Äh so richtig niederträchtiger, ja? Also der auch, wo man auch sagen kann, na ja
Das was der sagt, sagt äh immer mehr über ihn aus, als über die Menschen, die er beleidigt. Insofern fand ich das einfach nur ähm.
Ja, das war so ein bisschen ekelhaft, äh was er da gemacht hat, aber wie gesagt, der hat sich da, glaube ich, selber aller äh
Perspektiven in seinem Leben beraubt ist durch seine ekelhaften Äußerungen. Aber ähm er hat sich dann mit der Schorge, mit der ähm Schauspielerin aus dem Ghostbusters Film irgendwie angelegt und hat sie dann irgendwie auch wirklich wieder so so
ekelig und niederträchtig beleidigt und die Konsequenz davon war, dass Twitter dann gesagt hat, okay Corvette, ey,
Fuck you, also wir haben keinen Bock auf so ein, so einen Rassisten, der hier irgendwie Menschen die ganze Zeit beleidigt wird, wir suspendieren deinen Account
ja? Äh woraufhin dann Wiki Leaks irgendwie so einen riesigen, äh, so ein Interview gegeben hat und gesagt hat, das wäre hier der Cyber-Feudalismus von Twitter, dass sie diesen Menschen da seiner, seiner, seiner Meinungsfreiheit berauben,
und sie würden jetzt ihr sie, also von, das Lustige ist ja von Wiki Leas wird ja immer noch in der Mehrzahl gesprochen, dass ich ganz amüsant finde. Ähm,
Es würden jetzt ihr eigenes Twitter starten. Klammer auf, hatten sie ja schon mal, das war dieses Foul,
Friends of Wiki Leaks ist auch echt durch die Decke gegangen, das war wirklich irre. Äh dieses dieses Social Network Foul, also da was das alles für äh das war ja ein richtiger Hype damals, ne? Also es ist halt so richtig durch die Decke gegangen. Ähm.
Ja, also der.
Es tut mir leid, aber Julian Assange ist einfach auch nicht mehr ernst zu nehmen, in dem was er da macht und also diese diese Twitter kauen sich einfach mal durchzulesen. Da denkst du wirklich, okay.
Der Brauchmar, der muss echt mal in die frische Luft so. Also das ist äh.
Das steht leider gerade nicht ein für ihn.
Na ja, er hat ja diesen Balkon da, ne? Aber also.
Das scheint allein, aber nicht äh geholfen zu haben, ne.
Nicht zu helfen, ja? Na ja, dann hat er ähm kommen wir mal, also wir wir bleiben mal bei Vicky Leaks.
Im Übrigen möchte ich an der Stelle auch noch auf einen interessanten Bericht von Laury Penny, einer relativ bekannten Feministin verweisen, die irgendwie auch mit diesem Milo, wie heißt man gleich Milo, Janu.
Hast du nicht.
Äh bekannt ist und der auch,
Dazu muss man diesen Artikel mal lesen, um das irgendwie auch zu verstehen, was deren Verhältnis ist, weil die könnten sagen wir mal so in ihrer Positionierung, in ihrer gesellschaftlichen Position kaum weiter voneinander entfernt sein. Ja. Ähm trotzdem geschah es, dass äh
Earry Penny eingeladen wurde auf.
So einen republikanischen Event im Rahmen dieser Republiken äh Convention, die jetzt gerade um Trump herum stattgefunden hat,
wurde sich irgendwie schwule Republikaner zusammen gefunden haben. Es könnte kaum absurder sein, ja? Und wo ist es so eine eine Atmosphäre des Hasses irgendwie da ist. Ich erwähne das jetzt deshalb, weil,
Blick dafür zu bekommen, wie dieser Milo, Janopolis,
sich selber in diesem Twitter-Game sieht, ja, äh ist das, ist das sehr aufschlussreich. Kurz zusammengefasst, der Scheiß drauf, ja, für den ist das irgendwie sowieso tot und der benutzt einfach,
aktiv all diese Netzwerke einfach ich finde der Name troll ist an der Stelle eigentlich wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut gewählt ähm,
um, also verstehst du, die da wird gar nicht mehr aus irgendeinem, das ist meine Meinung heraus, Position heraus argumentiert, sondern da werden einfach diese Werkzeuge aktiv benutzt, um Reaktionen hervorzurufen
genau das Ergebnis, was äh am Ende bei rausgekommen ist, nämlich, dass er gesperrt wird, sieht er selber als seinen höchsten Sieger
Also das ist eine sehr sehr interessante Blick in diese Denkwelt von äh äh Trollen oder mal speziell eben diesen ganzen wahnsinnigen Trump herum. Also das ist,
Superscary. Ich tue den Link gleich noch dazu.
Super, wir bleiben nochmal kurz bei Wikis, denn äh sie Wiki Leaks hat auch noch,
die sogenannten DNC-Leagues veröffentlicht. Da sollen also Hacker insgesamt ein Jahr lang Zugriff auf die Systeme des DNCIdes Democratic National Council gehabt haben.
Ähm und außerdem sollen auch die Clinton Foundation soll auch die Clinton Foundation mutmaßlich von russischen Angreifern gehackt worden sein. Also Wiki League hat eine Reihe an E-Mails,
Eine ganze Menge an E-Mails der ähm,
der der US-Demokraten veröffentlicht. Und Juliana Sanche hat in einem TV-Intervall Interview bereits vor ein paar Wochen gesagt, äh wir haben noch viel mehr Material,
Und das wird schwerwiegende, rechtliche Konsequenzen für Hillary Clinton haben
Und er hat mehr oder weniger angekündigt, dass er davon ausgeht, dass sie äh quasi nicht.
Ihre Präsidentschaft erreicht, weil sie vorher eingeknastet wird. Ähm.
Jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, du hast es gerade schon angesprochen. Wir haben da so einen Donald Trump rumrennen. Und man fragt sich wirklich.
Da musst du schon sehr sehr radikal für diese komische Idee des Liegens sein, wenn du.
Mainz, dass ein Trump ein, also wenn du irgendetwas unternimmst, was in die Richtung führen könnte, dass Hillary Clinton nicht Präsidentin der Vereinigten Staaten wird. Es ist.
Sicherlich nicht die beste Kandidatin, aber es ist.
Keine psychische Erkrankung nachgewiesen. Und das ist, also sie ist nachweisbar äh,
Im Vollbesitz ihrer geistigen Kräfte und das ist ein nicht zu vernachlässigender Vorteil
Äh wenn du eine Weltmacht regierst, ähm insofern bin ich kein Clinton-Fan, aber diese Trump-Nummer ähm
ist natürlich eine Bedrohung äh für den Weltfrieden und die Weltwirtschaft und das ist ein das ist mit Sicherheit das größere Problem, ja?
Ähm.
Folge dieser DNC-League war, dass äh darin auch es sich Anhaltspunkte gefunden haben, wie sich die das Democratic National Council gegen Bernie Sanders verschworen hat,
und über ihn geschimpft hat und das ist das offenbar, echt, ist tatsächlich was dran. Insofern kann man das äh fast echt schon wieder äh kann man äh Sorge auch schon fast wieder sagen, okay, das musste einfach raus. Ähm,
Aber Bernie Sanders hat quasi da jetzt auch gesagt, nein, äh.
Selbst wenn das jetzt hier nicht fair war das Spiel, es ist trotzdem wichtiger, dass Hillary Clinton jetzt vor Donald Trump äh Präsidentin wird. Ähm Donald Trump als Reaktion auf dieses äh auf dieses League hat.
Etwas getan, was einfach.
Was man nur unter kommentieren kann mit. Donald Trump hat sich vor die Presse gestellt und hat gesagt.
Ähm Russland,
Falls ihr mich hört äh es wäre super, wenn ihr die fehlenden dreißigtausend Mails auch noch besorgen könntet. Wir haben hier eine Presse, die sich sehr darüber freuen würde.
Das heißt, ein Präsidentschaftskandidat hat einen mehr oder weniger offen verfeinerten Staat der USA
Mit dem die über Jahrzehnten keinen Krieg hatten und gegen den, gegen den, die gerade ein Wirtschaftsembar offen halten, mit dem die an der Grenze eines Krieges in der Ukraine standen, aufgefordert.
Eine Partei, die gegnerische Partei äh zu hacken. Ein Präsidentschaftskandidatin der Vereinigten Staaten zu hacken, seine Konkurrentin. Das ist.
Sie fordern ja auch schon, sie aufzuhängen, gefangen zu nehmen. Also von daher ist das jetzt keine nennenswerte Steigerung, ja. Es ist man fasst sich aber nur noch an Kop.
Nobady Cas, das ist das ist das ist eigentlich das allerschlimmste. Ich meine, stell dir so etwas in Deutschland vor. Der Wahlkampf wäre beendet
Ja? So eine Person wollte sich gar nicht mehr vor die Tür zu trauen. Zumindest ist das noch so und äh dort offensichtlich ist äh mittlerweile jegliche
ja äh alle alle Kräfte sind irgendwie.
Also das ist so, das ist so beängstigend. Also das ist wirklich einfach nur noch beängstigend.
Ja, als Fucking Scary.
Ist echt beängstigend.
Ja, vor allem, wenn man dann irgendwie äh auch noch Kommentare liest, wie den von äh Michel Moor, der einfach äh sagt, ja, Leute,
ja äh Donald Trump wird einfach jetzt gewinnen. Es wird stattfinden
weil die Doofen werden alle zur Wahl gehen, die sind alle so fanatisiert und alle so dermaßen in ihrem Anti-Establishment Rausch.
Einfach keine Möglichkeit hast mit der theoretischen Mehrheit von Minderheiten Latinos, Schwarze et cetera, alle die unter so einer Herrschaft zu leiden hätten, die Chris wo halt einfach nicht in dem Ofen vor.
Ja und dann hast du noch so und dann hast du noch irgendwie äh weitergehende andere Villay Clinton. Jetzt ist aber irgendwie noch ein zweiter linker Kandidat im Gespräch.
Na ja, gab's ja schon mal, also äh quasi die zweitausendeinser Wahl.
Ach so, meinst du jetzt von dem unabhängigen Lager bei den Librarys und bei den Grünen? Ja, gut, aber das wird, glaube ich, keine Linse aus.
Ralf Nader hat damals Elgor letztendlich die Wahl geko.
Ja gut, aber die Popularität äh hat in dem Lager einfach keiner.
Na ja, also,
Amerika äh Scheiße, Scheiße, Scheiße, Scheiße. Rückzug, Rückzug kann ich nur sagen, ey. Also echt nochmal hinfliegen vor der Wahl, habe ich mir jetzt auch vorgenommen, nochmal Abschied nehmen, ein paar ähm.
Und dann halt Rosinenbomber demnächst, ne? Also das ist, wenn man den.
Na ja okay, aber wir müssen mal hier weitermachen. Es gibt nämlich noch, es gibt nämlich noch was äh es gibt noch ein Web the fuck Moment. Also ich meine, wir haben ja sowieso Momente ohne Ende.
Ja, Wiki Leaks dreht durch, die komplette deutsche Netzpolitik dreht durch. Ähm.
Und jetzt scheint auch noch Edwards noton durchzudrehen. Ähm und präsentiert zusammen mit äh mit Bunny, einem äh sehr bekannten Hardwarehacker Andrew One Hang, Winghang. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das genau ausspricht. Ähm.
Weiß ja auch nicht Huang.
Unwingen, glaube ich, aber egal. Ähm Bunny.
Auch äh schon mehrmals glaube ich präsentiert auf dem CTC Kongress. Ein Gerät. Und zwar soll dieses Gerät das iPhone sicher machen.
So, sie sagen also Bedrohungsszenario ähm.
Journalisten, Frontline-Journalisten nennen sie es da, ja? Also sagen wir mal, jetzt investiger Tiefjournalisten oder so oder Journalisten in Krisengebieten. Ähm.
Haben jetzt nun mal diese Telefone dabei, diese Mobiltelefone. Äh die.
Ähm Computer sind, die wo es allerlei äh ungemacht gibt, was jetzt quasi äh Spionage angeht, die auf diese Geräte abzielen kann. Und,
sagen jetzt dieses große Problem auf der Welt, was es ist.
Möchten wir lösen, indem wir folgendes Bedrohungsszenario ähm.
Angehen. Das Bürgerdrohungsszenario ist, du hast dein Mobiltelefon im Airplay Mode,
Und es sendet trotzdem etwas. Ähm was passieren könnte, wenn.
Sagen wir mal, es von einem Trojaner befallen ist, der eben diesen Airplan-Mode in Wirklichkeit deaktiviert und dann eben dich belauscht und gleichzeitig das belauschte
raussendet, ähm was passieren könnte, wenn ähm
dein Mobiltelefon von Seiten des Netzes angegriffen wird mit einem Angriff auf das Baseband oder zum Beispiel ein äh Silent Call bekommt ähm,
also ein eine dein Telefon in Dauertransmission,
geschaltet wird, äh was tatsächlich möglich ist und gerne Anwendung findet, um dann die letzten Meter mit einer,
Peil Antenne äh dich zu ordnen mit
Also mit einem Imsi-Ketcher, was übrigens auch interessanterweise tatsächlich Anwendung findet ähm wenn äh US-Drohnen dicht äh mit als Mobiltelefon ordnen und dann töten. Das heißt, sie haben jetzt ein Gerät entwickelt, was dann in diesem Moment vorher kurz piept
Also bevor die Drohne äh dann ihre Rakete abschießt, äh piepend Mobiltelefon nochmal kurz. Ähm,
So, das heißt, du hast jetzt eine, du hast die Möglichkeit, sie schaffen also die Möglichkeit,
dir dich zu alarmieren, wenn dein Mobiltelefon sendet. Die Beurteilung, ob das jetzt gerade in deinem Sinne ist oder nicht, über äh überbleibt natürlich dir selber.
Ähm.
Das wird natürlich relativ einfach, wenn du das im Flugzeugmodus hast, hast, das wird aber schwer, wenn du es äh
Einfach im normalen Modus hast, weil es natürlich die ganze Zeit immer mal wieder sendet, um sich seines äh seiner seines Logins auf der Zelle äh zu vergewissern
um vielleicht mal gerade eine Push-Outification zu bekommen. Also die Radioaktivität deines Telefones kannst du als Laie,
relativ schwer äh in gut und böse unterteilen auch nicht mit Hilfe dieses Gerätes. So.
Nun kommen wir zu dem Punkt. Ich habe mich ja ein paar Jahre nun mit Mobilfunksicherheit auseinandergesetzt und,
Muss dabei einfach mal feststellen, ob dieses Gerät sendet oder nicht. Das konntest du früher, das war in den neunziger Jahren echt ein cooles Ding. Da hast du dir so kleine ähm.
AF äh Sticker ans Telefon gemacht oder so Schlüsselanhängergas auch. Da hatten die, also als Telefone noch nicht alle so ein wie Vibrator drin hat, ne? Das gab's ja, musste sie irgendwie bei Nokia auch so den Zusatzakku mit Vibrationsfunktion kaufen oder so, damit dann
dann wird dein Telefon subriert und dann hast du hier am bei den Ständen, die häufig an Bahnhöfen waren oder so, hast du so für,
Ja, wahrscheinlich acht bis neun Mark oder sowas. Äh so kleine Dinger bekommen, war eine LED drin.
Und die die haben im Prinzip die vom Ra von dem Mobiltelefon imitierten Funkwellen mittels einer Interne empfangen und wenn sie die empfangen haben,
ähm so LEDs blinken lassen. Dadurch konntest du also sehen, dieses Mobiltelefon sendet gerade. Ähm,
Das haben also jetzt Bunny und und Edwards Norden zwanzig Jahre später nochmal in,
in äh in in besser erfunden, indem sie natürlich jetzt nicht nur das GSM abdecken in neunhundert und achtzehnhundert Megahertz, sondern eben auch alle LTE-Bänder, weil sie tatsächlich
am Telefon selber,
ihre Probs haben und auch den Bluetooth-Teil und alles was das Ding irgendwie senden kann. Da haben sie halt kleine Löten sie dann Fühler dran und zeigen das auf dem Display an. Aber im Prinzip von der Evolution her.
Ähm nix an. Also ist da für zwanzig Jahre ist das relativ wenig Evolution, wenn ich das mal so bösartig.
Also ist dann jetzt auch so, dass sie tatsächlich nur reine Radioaktivität in dem Sinne äh auswerten, aber keinerlei die Picket inspection äh machen.
Nur sendet dieses Gerät oder nicht. So und jetzt äh jetzt kommt der Punkt. Warum ich das nicht nur für erstens,
Also es schützt sich vor nichts, sondern würde allenfalls Alarm schlagen. Also wie gesagt, du würdest dann im besten Fall warnte ich dieses Gerät kurz bevor dich die Rakete von der Drohne erwischt
oder äh warnt dich in dem Moment, wo du schon abgehört wirst, wenn man jetzt von so einem Silent Call ausgehen würde, wo aus irgendwelchen Gründen dein Mobiltelefon äh live äh dich abhört und das irgendwo hinsendet, ja?
Das Gerät hilft dir aber nicht, wenn dein Telefon von einem Trojaner befallen ist, der aufzeichnet und die Sachen nachher sendet. Das Gerät hilft dir nicht,
wenn du
Das Mobiltelefon zu deiner Quelle geschleppt hast und das bösefeindliche Mobilfunknetz das ohnehin immer weiß wo du bist, mitgelockt hat, hast, wo du hat, wo du hingegangen bist. Und das sind Szenarien, denen du grundsätzlich ausgesetzt bist,
dass dein, also dass dein Mobiltelefon getrackt wird.
Einfach grundsätzlich der Fall. Da brauchst du keine Hardware da dran zu klemmen. Das hat da kannst du auch mit dran geklemmter Hardware nichts gegen tun. Das heißt, was dieses Gerät tut, ist den Arm Frontline Journalist, die in so einem großen Risiko sind,
Ein Grund geben, ihr Telefon nicht nur mit zur Quelle zu nehmen, sondern es auch noch im Raum während des Gespräches liegen zu lassen,
Damit einerseits,
dass die die Ortung grundsätzlich nicht nur zu ermöglichen, sondern durchzuführen und zweitens bei einem Trojanerbefall des Telefones äh das zu ermöglichen, dass das Telefon dort in Hörweite liegt.
Du willst es ja sehen, du willst ja sehen, ob es ob es äh sendet. Das heißt, du hast es nehmen, du hast das Mikrofon neben dir liegen, während du mit deiner Quelle sprichst. Und hast das ordnbare Gerät wahrscheinlich kurz vorher ausgeschaltet. Das heißt.
Greifen ein Bedrohungsszenario auf, was erstmal grundsätzlich sehr unrealistisch ist oder sehr unwahrscheinlicher ist, äh ähm Entschuldigung, ein Bedrohungsszenario auf, was unwahrscheinlicher als die anderen ist.
Können dich davor nur warnen und dich nicht schützen.
Und bring dich damit unter Berücksichtigung der anderen Bedrohungsszenarien in größere Gefahr. Denn alle Bedrohungsszenarien wirst du los, wenn du das Scheißtelefon einfach zu Hause lässt.
Und jeder, der dich motiviert, genau das nicht zu tun, bringt dich in Summe, in größere Gefahr,
Und ich finde es wirklich katastrophal, ähm dass sie äh dass sie das tun und dieses,
bewerben. Okay, ist jetzt Quelloffen, wird nicht, wird im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich am Ende auch nie produziert werden, weil wenn bevor sich das jemand bauen lässt oder kauft, äh wird da hoffentlich nochmal mit jemandem reden, der davon Ahnung hat, aber es ist letztendlich genauso ein Scheiß
wie diese schon seit schon vor Jahren von Künstlern mal Spaßhalsheiber produzierten
ARF Schiels, wo du also dein Telefon in so einen kleinen Faridation-Käfig äh packst ähm und dadurch dann sicher sein kannst, dass es nicht in der Lage sein wird, daraus zu senden.
Ähm es wobei dann da klar, dann kommen wieder die Fragen bei welcher äh bei welcher Frequenz oder sonst was. Letztendlich,
Sicher kannst du dir nur sein, wenn du das Scheißding zu Hause lässt. Und das mitzunehmen ist das ist die Gefahr und mit diesem Ding dran bist du in einer größeren Gefahr, als wenn du das Ding ablässt,
Ja, also es ist wirklich von vorne bis hinten, du holst schon Luft, es ist Bullshit und es ist gefährlicher das zu haben, als es nicht zu haben.
Also ich habe jetzt nicht genau äh gelesen, wie Snowden, das selber jetzt präsentiert
Ähm man könnte natürlich jetzt hier auch eine andere Perspektive einnehmen, um das Ganze einfach als technisches äh Wertexperiment werten und nicht mit dem Versprechen, mit das macht dich sicher, ja?
Habe ich jetzt so auch noch nicht gelesen, steht vielleicht irgendwo, keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall allein als technisches Experiment. Zu sehen, also ein Gerät zu haben.
Was dir anzeigt, dass eine Aktivität vorliegt, wo keine sein sollte. Das halte ich jetzt,
Nicht für ein verwerfliches Ding. Man muss ja nicht automatisch daraus ableiten, dass er in das in irgendeiner Form
sicher macht, weil das verhindert ja in dem Sinne nichts, sondern es ist ja nichts anderes mehr als so ein ja äh Radiometer, der der am Ende visualisiert, dass äh eine eine Kommunikation stattfindet, so,
Das muss einen ja nicht.
Du bist nicht in der Lage zu bewerten, ob das was sinnvoll ist, ob das gut ist, was es da tut oder nicht. Uns bewerben es explizit nicht
als ein ey guck mal hier kannst du gucken, ob dein Telefon vielleicht irgendwie Scheiße baut, sondern sie bewerben es als
gezielte Schutzmechanismus, Countring Lovle Users of Digital Sivalens. Das ist,
sie bewerben es introduction in Problem Statement. Das erste Wort ist Frontline Journalist, Risk the Lifes, Touriport vom Conflict Regens. Und mit diesem Gerät bringen sie ihr Leben in größere Gefahr als ohne.
Sorry. Keine Debatte. Ich habe selber
ja schon mal hier erwähnt, dass ich an äh an der Entwicklung von solchen Monitoring-Technologien äh beteiligt war, die also die aufzeichnen, was macht dieses Telefon? Und dabei äh zum Beispiel helfen können äh,
anzumerken, wenn oder zu detektieren, wenn dein Mobiltelefon von einem äh Insi-Catcher gefangen wird, aber auch die sind,
haben wir niemals als Schutzmechanismen den Leuten gegeben, sondern als quasi Mess- und Prüfinstrumente. Und die Sicherheit kriegst du, wenn das Scheißding nicht dabei hast.
Sorry.
Sorry. Also das ist wirklich richtig gefährlicher Unsinn.
Gut.
Jeder, der dir, der dir ein sicheres Mobiltelefon gibt, äh verkauft dir gefährlichen Unsinn übrigens. Also der, der, der dir sagt, das kannst du bei kannst du in einer kritischen Situation,
Im Raum oder in der Umgebung lassen, wer das behauptet, bringt dich in Gefahr. Wir kommen zu den Kurzmeldungen.
Genau. Jetzt sieht's wieder lustig.
Felix Dooke hat mal wieder zugeschlagen. Äh es sei ja wirklich mehrere Monate, dass Opel bestritten hat, dass sie ab Abschaltvorrichtungen in ihrem Modell Safira hatten, also wir reden wieder von äh Diesel äh,
Abschalt äh so Dieselabgasschutzabschalt vor,
Einrichtungen. Ähm, also um Abgasmanipulation an diese Motoren monatelang hat Opel das bestritten. Sie haben ja da auch gesagt,
äh vereinzelten Erkenntnisse, die die Erkenntnisse eines einzelnen Hackers äh könnten hier äh nix dazu beitragen. Ähm jetzt haben sie aber eine Kehrtwende vollzogen und wollen die Software nachbessern
denn das Verkehrsministerium hatte ihn gedroht, die Typzulassung zu verweigern.
Äh nachdem äh Felix Domke nachgewiesen hatte, dass die Abgasreinigung in einer Vielzahl von realen Fahrsituationen massiv verringert wird. Zum Beispiel,
bei Außentemperaturen unter siebzehn Grad. Bei Geschwindigkeiten über einhundertvierzig Kilometer,
oder bei einem starken Beschleunigung, bei einem starken Beschleunigen des Fahrzeuges hat es nämlich sehr viel mehr Schadstoffe ausgestoßen, al,
vorgeschriebenen Test. Also hier auch eine gezielte Manipulation, um das Testprogramm äh auszutrick,
Tricksen und im Real äh unter realen Bedingungen sehr viel mehr Abgas auszustoßen und da hat Felix mal wieder.
Den langen Atem bewiesen. Der wird jetzt glaube ich als Berater so von allen möglichen,
herangezogen in diesem Bereich äh und ja ist immer wieder eine Freude äh zu lesen äh wie er sich da wie er da eine Control United Nacht der anderen auseinander nimmt und äh die Manipulation nachweist.
Ja und vor allem das Ganze nur so äh gestartet aus diesem reinen Urhacker äh Trieb mit. Ich habe so eine Karre, ich schaue da jetzt mal rein, mal gucken, was da wirklich Sache ist und schon macht man sich ein komplett neues Businessfeld auf.
Hatte das glaube ich ja schon, ich hatte das ja glaube ich schon erzählt und ich glaube der verletzt sich jetzt nicht die Vertraulichkeit, wenn nicht,
sage wie ich irgendwann, ich glaube im Dezember diese Mail äh bekam, ja äh guck mal, ich habe hier, ich habe mir mal hier so eine Engine Control United angesehen, paar interessante Sachen gefunden, wäre vielleicht cool, dass auf dem Kongress zu präsentieren. Während der war natürlich der CFB schon längst tut, alles lots weg und dann hatten wir ihn ja am Ende zusammengelegt
mit einem zweiten welcher Name war das ähm.
Felix Dunkel, zweiunddreißig, C drei.
Mit Daniel Lange. Daniel Lange und Felix Dunke hatten da den äh Dieselgate Exost Emissions Scandle Vortrag beim zweiunddreißig C drei.
Das war auch eine ganz gute Kombination unterm Strich.
War eine super Kombination, auch ein Vortrag, den man sich echt immer noch mal wieder anschau.
Selten selten, dass sowas äh so gut funktioniert. Also, dass man so zwei.
Sich ja auch vorher nicht, ne? Die hatten irgendwie einen Tag äh vorher sich kennengelernt, haben aber natürlich über Telefon und so sich schon sehr viel abgesprochen. Jetzt habe ich da relativ viel darüber erzählt. Ich hoffe, da darf ich aber jetzt nirgendwo irgendwas,
irgendwelche Privatsphäre verletzt, denke ich mal, habe ich, glaube ich, auch eh schon.
Bestimmt nicht.
Bestimmt, ne, ne. Wisst ihr, wo der wohnt? Kommt ihr nie drauf,
Äh steht aber hier in der Zeitung, sage ich aber jetzt nicht. Okay, dann kommen wir äh nächste Kurzmeldung.
Die neue Störerhaftung ist jetzt in Kraft, also das äh zweite Gesetz für Änderungen des Telemediengesetzes
ist in Kraft getreten, das ist jenes, welches WLAN-Anbieter vor der Haftung für Rechtsverstöße von anderen Nutzern schützen soll und über das es
sehr unterschiedliche Einschätzungen gibt.
Inwiefern das wirksam sein wird. Die Abmahnkanzlei Walldorf-Frommer hatte ja schon vor lauten lassen. Auch für uns ändert sich da eigentlich nichts. Äh die,
digitale Gesellschaft und andere netzaktivistische Einrichtungen haben, das ebenfalls gesagt, aber die Regierung ist ja sehr überzeugt,
dass das jetzt dem Abmahnwesen endlich ein äh ein Ende.
Also.
Wir werden es erleben, ja?
Wir werden's erleben. Ab jetzt müsste also eigentlich alles gut sein, äh sollte irgendwas nicht gut sein, dann äh könnt ihr das ja entsprechend verlautbaren.
Und dann enden wir mit einer Nachricht aus Brasil.
Ich denke in der letzten Sendung haben wir schon äh angesprochen, dass äh Chelsea Mening in Haft.
Einen äh einen Suizidversuch unternommen hat und ähm,
der den überlebt hat zum Glück. Äh sie ist jetzt auch wieder,
Ähm also sie ist jetzt quasi wieder raus, sie hat auf auf Twitter äh auch schon äh sich zu Wort gemeldet.
Und sich für die vielen äh Solidaritätsbegründungen bedankt und so. Und jetzt wurde ähm sie aber mit einem äh mit einer,
mit einem Dokument vertraut gemacht, dass es nun eine offizielle Untersuchung ihres Fehlverhaltens gäbe.
Und zwar habe sie sich im Rahmen dieses äh Suizidversuches mehrerer ähm vergehen.
Potenziell schuldig gemacht? Ähm.
Darunter der Vorwurf, jetzt hole ich hier gerade die äh.
Ja äh Resisting the Force, Move Team,
In der Kategorie vier oder fünf, also Widerstand gegen äh die äh Justizbeamten.
Pro Hibit, Propagy, also Besitz eines verbotenen Gegenstandes. Das Problem hatte sie schon mal vor ein paar Jahren, da hatte sie eine abgelaufene Tube Zahnpasta
äh die ihr dann aus der ihr dann eine Stricke dreht äh werden sollte. Und Condact Wich Fratons, also ein.
Eine Führung, die bedroht, ja? Also so verhalten, bedrohliches Verhalten, äh kann man das glaube ich bezeichnen. Und ähm die.
Potenzielle Folge dieser äh Untersuchung ähm sind allerlei ähm Haftverschärfungen.
Auch 'ne geile Logik ist, ne?
Darunter ähm einzelhaft auf unbestimmte Zeit, potenziell sogar für den Rest der Zeit,
Sie ist momentan im sechsten Jahr ihres fünfunddreißig Jahre umfassenden Urteils. Das heißt, die ist länger, also die die ist eine Haftstrafe verurteilt, die länger ist als mein ganzes Leben.
Davon hat sie jetzt sechs Jahre weg. Neunundzwanzig noch vor sich? Eines der Ergebnisse könnte sein, dass sie den Rest dieser Zeit in.
Isolationshaft verbringt. Die Reklassifizierung in den Hochsicherheitstrakt, also da bist du natürlich dann ähm.
Da unterliegst du einfach sehr viel stärkeren ähm Auflagen und eine potenzielle äh Hinzuführung von neun Jahren in äh Medienkasse, die Medienkasse, die heißt, du hast Ausgang
Muss aber abends wieder zurück in den Knast, ne? Also das, was man so.
Hoeneß.
Ja so Hoenesty. Hoffentlich nicht mit Uli Hoeneß zusammen. Nee, der ist ja schon raus, den haben wir ja längst, ist ja längst raus, Uli Hoeneß, wo denken sie hin? Ja, kleiner Kavalierstil, da. Ja komm.
So viel für den Fußball getan. Kann man doch mal auch mal ein Auge äh da unten Auge zudrücken. Ja, das heißt, die.
Haftbedingungen, also nochmal kurz als als Erinnerung äh Chelsea Mening ist als transsexuelle Frau in einem vollständig männlichen Knast, ne. Die anderen äh Insassen sind männlich, ihre äh Leute da sind männlich ähm,
Und sie ist aber in quasi,
Negligens ihres, ihres, ihrer äh gefühlten Sexualität dort als einzige Frau äh drin untergebracht. Die Bedingungen der Haft haben sie also in gerade mal sechs Jahren an den Rand des Suizids getrieben und,
Das kann ja wohl nicht sein. Deswegen werden genau diese Bedingungen nun eventuell.
Als Reaktion auf ihren auf diesen Versuch verschärft. Das ist.
Gelinde gesagt ähm pervers.
Und ähm mir fällt da auch wirklich nichts mehr zu ein. Ich habe dann oder wir haben vom vom CC dann mal eine äh,
Solidaritätsbegründung äh veröffentlicht und darin die Hoffnung geäußert, dass ja.
Ähm Barack Obama jetzt bald scheiden wird als US-Präsident,
Traditionell nutzen scheidende US-Präsidenten ihr Recht auf Begnadigung, ja? Das heißt so in den letzten Wochen ihrer Regentschaft ähm.
Können sie noch Leute begnadigen und ich würde doch wirklich sehr hoffen, äh dass Barack Obama ähm von dieser Möglichkeit im bei Chelsea Mening Gebrauch macht,
Ähm und wir haben dieser Forderung mal als äh CC Ausdruck verliehen, denn
ich habe das ja in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt, dieses äh Schicksal geht mir
äh wirklich persönlich auch nochmal echt nah. Vor allem, wenn du dann siehst, dass so eine äh so ein Arschloch äh Julian Assange da äh irgendwie jetzt nur noch frei dreht und irgendwie
also wirklich nicht mehr nachvollziehbare Äußerungen tätig äh während diese
Person da echt einfach mal auf Ewigkeiten in Haft verdorrt und glaube ich auch sehr im Schatten ähm,
von Edwatch äh Snowden steht. Insofern alle äh Solidarität jetzt wirklich gebrauchen kann. Die Adresse, die wir letzte Mal schon verlinkt haben.
Ist äh tatsächlich auch die, unter der man äh sich noch an sie wenden kann,
und ich denke jede jeder Brief und auch jede Geldspender an ihren Defense fand oder auch an ihr ähm.
Quasi an ihr Knastkonto, mit dem sie sich dann da irgendwie Briefmark kaufen kann äh ist natürlich äh an einem für einen Zweck aufgewendet, der äh wirklich ähm wichtig ist.
Gut.
Ja, wollen wir noch Eigenwerbung machen? Wenn wir jetzt Eigenwerbung machen, dann rege ich mich nun wieder auf. Weil ich jetzt irgendwie so so festgestellt habe, dass es ja so ganz äh.
Das ist jetzt das jetzt so dieses mit diesem Spotify und diesem Audible, ne?
Ja, wie kommst du auf jetzt?
Ja, habe ich irgendwie gestern auf Twitter gesehen. Ich dachte, ich wäre nicht mehr. Ich habe das vorher, war mir das nicht klar, dass es dass man jetzt irgendwie, dass man sich jetzt irgendwie.
In diese geschlossene Audible Hölle bewegen kann, um dort kostenlose Podcasts anzubieten. Das äh.
Sogenannte Podcasts anzubieten. Also das ist mir äh unbegreiflich, wie man das überhaupt in Erwägung ziehen kann.
Na ja, also.
Wird wird bezahlt wahrscheinlich, ne?
Mich auch bezahlt.
Ach so, ja,
Ja stimmt, also die Podcast-Community ist ja eine, die echt durch äußerste Knausrigkeit äh auffällt und da wird einem ja echt nichts gedankt. Insofern äh ist das ja wirklich,
angebracht
äh da einfach mal äh über Stöckchen eines kommerziellen Anbieters zu springen und dessen äh Abozeilen in die Höhe zu treiben. Also nee, ist völlig nachvollziehbar.
Was bringt es gut.
Also es ist ja, nee, ganz klar, natürlich, echt.
Also ja, vor allem wenn man ne jahrelang äh für diese Podcast-Community eigentlich nichts anderes äh übrig hatte, als
irgendwie rumgenörgelt an der an der Software, die da zur Anwendung kommt und dass das für die ist bestimmt jetzt für die Mutter sehr viel einfacher, wenn sie nur noch ein Audible Account abschließen muss.
Dann die Audible App runterladen muss.
Und dann nach äh Ende der Probezeit Geld dafür bezahlen muss, ist das wahrscheinlich für die Mutter sehr viel einfacher, als wenn die eine Podcasting-App nutzt.
Ja, da sind da auch nicht so viel verwirrende äh Features äh dabei. Bitte bitte Marken oder so, die einem das Leben dann leichter machen könnten, sondern man muss einfach man kriegst einfach nackt um die Ohren gehauen. Man muss damit klarkomm.
Nee, das ist, das ist sehr viel, also das ist sehr viel besser, das ist echt die Zukunft und äh da kann man echt froh sein, dass die Pioniere sich da jetzt reinbewegen. Kann man echt froh sein, das ist echt toll.
Wir machen das nicht. Oder wolltest du zu Audible jetzt.
Nee, lieber nicht.
Produkt jetzt schon mehrfach erwähnt hast.
Ja sorry sorry für die Erwähnung, wir piepen das nachher raus. Ähm ich finde das also ich mir ist naja, du hast das,
Du hast jetzt schon sehr viel früher natürlich erkannt und auch hier in der Sendung schon mal gesagt, aber dieses dieses Podcasting ist im Prinzip das Einzige, ähm was noch nicht von irgend so einer Massen-Publishing-Plattform aufgefressen wurde
Ähm die was irgendwie mal freies Veröffentlichen von Musik irgendwo war.
Also man könnte Blogs auch noch mit dazu zählen. Das ist eine etwas schwierige D.
Ja, aber die wurden ja, da gibt's ja auch die große, die großen Bloganbieter, ne, die dann irgendwie Tumbler und der ähm und Blogger oder sowas. Man könnte Blogs noch mit wohlwollend dazuziehen. Ähm.
Es, also es ist es ist ein ein,
Es ist ein machbarer Vergleich, er hinkt natürlich äh weil es sich hier einfach um ganz andere Kanäle handelt. Ich denke auch, dass man die audiovisuellen Medien und Textmedien sowieso nicht so ohne Weiteres in einem äh Top werfen
kann. Also schon ist schon klar. Also wir haben hier sozusagen noch eine gewisse Eigenständigkeit, ja? Hater würden sagen,
Bedeutungslosigkeit. Ja, so nach dem Motto erst, wenn etwas irgendwie Bedeutung erfährt, äh dann dann wird es dadurch geadet, dass es eben solche Übernahme äh Angebote bekommt.
Also ich bin da, ich bin da tatsächlich ähm.
Also warum mich das so persönlich auch ein bisschen.
Also wirklich einfach persönlich traurig macht, wenn ich sowas sehe, ist weil ich natürlich selber.
Angst habe irgendwann auch diesen Schritt gehen zu müssen,
ja? Ähm wir hatten ja also wir haben diese Debatte zum Beispiel ja glaube ich auch hier schon mal öffentlich bei YouTube, ja? Pumpen wir unser Logbuchnetzkritik auch nochmal bei YouTube rein, um uns die YouTuber irgendwie als potenzielle ähm,
Zielgruppe zu ermöglichen.
Nee, war ich, ich habe das ja öfter mal als Idee äh mit in den Raum gestellt. Wir sind da irgendwie nicht auf einer gemeinsamen Nenner gekommen. Ähm.
Aber irgendwie so so Bezahlschranken kostenlos Angebote von irgendwie solchen von solchen Dingern. Ich hoffe, dass wenn die gezwungen sein werden, ähm das selber zu machen. Ähm wenn aber natürlich jetzt.
Diese Community, Schwanzwedelnd in diese Dinger reinrennt und den diesen Konzern dabei hilft das aufzubauen.
Dann wird er unter Umständen irgendwann ein Sog entstehen, dem auch wir uns nicht mehr entziehen können. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist es jetzt gerade wichtig, dass,
einerseits die die Podcaster äh standhaft bleiben und andererseits eben auch die,
die hörenden eben mal erkennen, was das hier echt für eine besondere Sache ist. Verteilte Veröffentlichung über
selbst gehostete, eigene Plattformen komplett individuell gemacht mit mit einer Community, mit einer Communitynähe, wo Menschen seit,
vielen Jahren letztendlich komplett
kostenlose Angebote bereitstellen. Das ist ein, das ist ein Wert in sich, den ich glaube ich in zuvor für mich auch selber noch nicht so ganz begriffen hatte, bis ich jetzt eben festgestellt habe, dass es da eben einige,
äh Leute gibt, die äh für die das eben nichts wert ist. Ne, ist ja so, also wie sagt er das Oskar Wild äh.
Man kennt von allem den den Preis aber von nichts den Wert,
und äh das sind natürlich dann auch die ersten, die sich solchen Angeboten widmen. Schade, ich find's einfach nur schade.
Ja es ähm es bleibt auf jeden Fall ähm schwierig. Mh,
ich finde in gewisser Hinsicht dann auch so Vorstöße wie von Google tatsächlich sogar noch als ein bisschen problematischer in der aktuellen Perspektive,
weil die sozusagen ohne, dass sie einem Geld bezahlen, einem zu irgendwelch,
äh Dingen zwingen, äh in dem Moment, wo dieses Podcast David von Google ausgerollt wird und sie dann ganz gerne für einen für die Daten ausliefern wollen,
wenn man das nicht will, dass man halt nicht drin in dem Verzeichnis, dann wird man halt auch nicht mehr gefunden, hm? Also das ist äh so ein anderes Problem, was aufkommt. Na ja.
Ja, das ist äh sicherlich auch eins. Ähm da bin ich ja ein bisschen, da bin ich ja ein bisschen, mir ist es ja so ein bisschen egaler. Wichtig ist eigentlich, dass es frei zugänglich ist für alle und ob das nun auf Google Servern liegt, ja, wer er also ist, ist nicht die reine Lehre, aber.
Verletzt verletzt auch bestimmte technische, fundamental Prinzipien, aber ähm.
Ändert erstmal in der Sache der freien Zugänglichkeit nichts. Ich glaube unsere unsere Lizenz würde es würde es Google grundsätzlich sogar erlauben.
Ja, bei der Hänger hängen auch noch andere Sachen drin, ne? Nämlich äh die Möglichkeit äh moritänische Innovationen über Formate, et cetera äh zu fördern, äh et cetera und in dem Moment, wo einem das aus der Hand genommen wird, wird's einem eben aus der Hand genommen,
lange Diskussion passt jetzt hier auch nur begrenzt äh rein. Äh ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen hier,
aufs Ende der Sendung drängen, die Zeit ist knapp. Äh, wir freuen uns, euch mal wieder eine Sendung geliefert zu haben. Wir machen jetzt mal keine Zusage in den nächsten Woche äh wann.
Gucken mal wie das so ist.
Wir gucken mal wie das äh so ist. Vielleicht geht da was, vielleicht dauert's äh dann auch noch ein bisschen länger. Der August ist ja traditionell äh,
etwas ausgedünnt im äh in der Podcastlandschaft aus auch schon genannten Gründen. Insofern.
Gilt der Dank Carola.
Genau. Und auch allen anderen und äh wir möchten euch natürlich auch weiterhin ermuntern äh uns Feedback zu geben, sehr gerne in den Kommentaren
zur Sendung, das ist eigentlich so der Premiumbereich, weil da hat man immer den Kontext und andere Leute, die kommentieren et cetera, man kann sich darauf beziehen und nicht selten sind das auch sehr wertvolle Fortsetzung unserer
Diskussionen,
wer Lust hat über die Sendung zu chatten, kann sich hier in die Mittebene Community den Slack da begeben und da auch noch weiter debattieren,
noch etwas äh interaktiver. Na ja und ansonsten äh haben wir natürlich Twitter und äh Dinus freut sich mal ein bis,
Kommentare auf Facebook.
Egal, also Facebook, Face, der auf Facebook gibt es ein Unique äh Feature im Moment. Äh schon seit einiger Zeit. In Facebook,
Auf der Facebookseite werden Links zu den Artikeln äh und Nachrichten veröffentlicht, die wir
für die Sendungsvorbereitung heranziehen. Also das heißt, da da auf der Facebookseite verbreiten wir, das ist eigentlich nur eine Linksschleuder
aber eben dann zu den Artikeln, die wir
für die Sendungsvorbereitung heranziehen und dann eben auch mal ganz gerne zum Thema, was vielleicht am Ende nicht reinschafft, ne? Also irgendwie so ein, wo man sagt, okay, das Thema hat's jetzt gerade nicht reingeschafft, das würdet ihr dann trotzdem
zeitnah auf der Facebook-Seite finden. Ähm was dafür halte ich die für sehr gut. Ähm,
Was schwierig ist, ist, wenn ihr auf der Facebook-Seite tatsächlich kommentiert oder der Facebook-Seite irgendwie Nachrichten schickt, weil diese komische Facebook-App
mich überfordert und ich dann nicht also man kann nicht sagen sag mir nur bei Nachrichtenbescheid und deswegen piept ihr die ganze Zeit wenn irgendeiner,
Das Ding rief Facebook oder oder Pfaff oder so, liked, heißt das ja.
Und wenn das geschieht, also da diesen, diese Flut anpiepen, die kann man irgendwie nicht wegmachen, das hört nicht auf. Das sind Stop und äh deswegen gehen da Nachrichten und Kommentare,
unter. Deswegen Kommentare sehr viel besser ähm direkt bei ähm bei,
Logbuch Minus Netzpolitik DE, beziehungsweise nicht beleidigt sein, wenn wenn wir dann auf Facebook eben nicht antworten.
So sieht's aus. Wir sagen tschüss.
Vielen Dank, ciao ciao.
Bis bald.